this is
state versus barristone indictment
1912.00999-1
we're continuing with the trial
you may have appearances
good morning arms you're honored who's
of course christopher sheldon crystal's
the record will reflect mr barrison as
president court
just improper trial attire
all right we're ready to proceed with
your witness we are judge can i just put
one thing on the record sure uh for this
morning um i anticipate calling vanessa
medrano cortez today who is the dcpmp
worker your honor had signed a
protective order on january 31st 2020
releasing certain dcp records to the
parties uh and in that order it
indicates on page two no party or
counsel for any party shall make
reference to the substance of it within
bcpnp records in the public domain
without prior
leave of the court
judge we did mark those i believe it's
15 pages as s174
i don't intend to introduce that as an
exhibit but i may refer to it with the
witness if she needed a direct
uh recollection refreshed or something
in that issue all right very good thank
you all right let's call the jurors
so
oh
uh
good morning everyone please be seated
we're going to continue with the trial
in state versus barizone
we're going to continue with the direct
examination of dr ruth cox
you want to call in your witness yes
john if we could call dr ruth cox
doctor
morning doctor well good morning to you
how are you very well thank you um we
need to re-sway you since we broke
during the day so left hand on the bible
raise your right hand my clerk will
administer the oath do you swing the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
yes ma'am please state your name and
spell your last name for the record ruth
penix cox last name c o x thank you
thank you doctor have a seat thank you
please continue mr shellhorn
thank you your honor good morning dr cox
good morning
i think we left off yesterday uh just
before i was going to ask you some
questions about august 7th but i did
just want to follow up on two things we
discussed yesterday
the first is uh
with respect to the gun s 177 in
evidence
and if you remember yesterday
it was turned the other way
i asked you to show the jury where the
magazine release button was and you
couldn't see it because the
gun was turned around so if you could
just stand up and just point out to the
jury where that button is
it's black
so it's that button that's right next to
where the trigger guard is okay
thank you that's it it was just turned
around yesterday i understand yes sir
judge i'd also like permission
to move s-401 into evidence it's a
have you seen s401
all right no objection s 401 will be
admitted into evidence
doctor we talked yesterday about the
night that michael barisson asked you
for the gun do you remember that yes sir
i did and i think you had told the jury
that you were
near or around the state the stall where
didi was yes sir i'm showing you what's
uh been marked as s-401
do you recognize what s 401 is a picture
of yes sir i did can you tell the jury
what that's a picture yes
this is the stall
that i was spending the nights at
michael had concern about um my horse's
safety and he had asked me to spend the
nights there in front of his stall
so that's the stall where dd was was
house
what are those uh areas just to the left
of the stall those are two wash stalls
and is that horse that we see in the
picture dd
i can't tell you whether that that's him
or not unless you could show me his face
i can't tell you it's kind of the right
color
but it looks like a horse has been
clipped but i couldn't there were many
many horses there
all right doctor i want to draw your
attention to uh august 7th now wednesday
august 7th do you remember what you were
doing that morning
uh yes sir the long table that's there
uh in the club room i was at the end of
that table that is closest to the front
of the building there were two windows
there with my laptop doing work
and at some point do you remember if you
were told or you became aware that there
was someone from child protection at the
farm
uh yes sir do you remember approximately
what time of day that was
i'm my best guess would be sometime mid
midday noon times
noon to one
something like that i could not give you
an exact time
you were you were engrossed in your work
yes sir
do you remember if that caseworker was a
man or a woman there was a woman
do you recall how you became aware that
that caseworker was at the farm yes sir
i do
mary haskins asked me came over and
asked me if i would be willing to talk
to her she had some questions
about michael and the children and she
asked me if i would come and answer her
questions and i agree to do that and do
you recall where you spoke with the case
yes sir can you tell the jury yes sir
so
uh
in the pictures uh
if you i'm assuming they've seen
pictures of the club room yes okay so
where the pool table was there's a door
to the left of that pool table that is a
core door between the uh club room into
michael's work garage where he had his
cars and there's doors on either side of
that so we went because there were
people milling around so we went into
that area and we went to the father's
corner that you could go in that area
and we stood there and talked besides
you and the caseworker was anyone else
present mary haskins was there
were the doors open or closed they were
closed
now do you know where the defendant was
at the time you went to speak with the
caseworker no no sir i do not
did you see at any point if or when he
left the area of the barn
i can tell you that because of where i
was sitting at the end of that table
with the window there i saw his truck
he had two silver trucks i saw his truck
go down the driveway down the hill
toward the house
i assumed it was hand driving
driving that what's it hold on doctor
what's the basis
all right
clarify your questions
or lay a foundation you didn't see who
was driving that truck no sir i did not
was that before or after you went into
the hallway with the caseworker
oh oh that would be after so after you
were talking to the caseworker you went
back to the
table and that's when you saw the truck
yes sir
did you see uh the defendant
running around the the clubhouse or the
stable that afternoon
i saw him around around the area yes
was he yelling or screaming or carrying
on any of that anything of that nature
no sir
now at some point that afternoon on
august 7th did you become aware that
police were at the property yes sir
and without getting into specifics of
what someone may or may not have told
you how did you generally become aware
mary haskins father was there and he i
got some information from him that
concerned me that something had happened
down at the house and what did you do as
a result of that i got in my truck and
drove down there
how when you say down there you mean to
the house to the house uh could you see
the house from when you got into your
truck at the parking lot and started to
drive yes sir i could you could see the
house from the parking lot
what you said once i got in my truck and
started to drive down the hill yes sir
okay so after you got to the top of the
hill you started to drive you could see
the house yes i could
how close did you get to the area of the
house not very close because there were
many many police cars down there there
were many many policemen
and
i got
probably
thinking about yards i probably got
15 yards
so if the house is here
the driveway's here i probably got about
15 yards up the driveway and was stopped
am i being clear with that answering
your question i think so so you didn't
get all the way to the driveway no sir
into the bathroom oh no sir there's no
way you could have gotten in there
did you see uh michael barrasson in the
area yes i did and you recall oh can you
describe how he
whether he was standing sitting kneeling
or something else
uh at one point
he was kneeling
there was a policeman
standing behind him
his his arms were
behind him like that
and then at another time he was sitting
next to the wheels
of
i don't know if it was a trailer or a
car that was there in the parking lot
no i think you said yesterday that at
some time after the police got to the
scene and after the investigation began
that you
were advised or you learned that your
firearm had been recovered by the police
yes
were you asked that night on august 7th
2019 about your file yes sir and were
you shown a picture of a black and pink
nine millimeter ruger by a detective yes
sir
what did you think when the
police officer showed you that picture
my heart sank
i didn't hardly think anything my
heart's sane
and had you seen that gun again since
you gave it to michael barisson in this
in the stable a couple of nights earlier
i had not seen that gun again until you
showed it to me in the courtroom did i
understand your question correct i think
so
do you still have any ongoing business
with either mary haskins greg
no i do not how about do you have any
ongoing business with the defendant no
sir i do not
george i don't have any further
questions thank you
what cross-examination
miss cox uh
you were charged with a criminal offense
correct
yes sir
and
you agreed to
testify
as part of your plea agreement correct
yes sir
now
the prosecutor just asked you questions
concerning
you
being shown a picture of your gun on the
night
of the incident correct yes sir
and and that's the
question where you said your heart
stopped correct yes sir
yeah
you told the police at that time that
you weren't sure if it was you were done
correct yes sir
but deep down in your heart you knew it
was your gun correct
i strongly thought it was my gun yes sir
was there any doubt in your mind
that the gun that they were showing you
at that time
was your gun
well there was a little bit of hope that
it wasn't my gun
until i knew that it was the same serial
number as my gun
now
you've been coming to the farm for
approximately five years correct yes
you're coming up this last time that was
what friday before the wednesday uh
incident yes sir
um
is it a fact that you were asked to come
up
uh by michael barrison
no sir that's not correct who asked you
to come on
i was not directly asked to come up
i had some exchanges uh with mh mary
haskins and she told me what was going
on up there
and i had i had had plans to come a week
or so later
and as she and i talked about it we
decided that perhaps it was best that i
come on up that weekend
you basically came up
out of the goodness of your heart to
help them correct that is absolutely
correct sir
and that is after
you were told by mary haskins exactly
what
was going on at least according to her
correct yes sir
and you were told
can i assume some pretty horrible things
yes sir
now
you were there for
what four or five days before the
incident
yes sir
and and
would you agree with me that
the entire
the entire uh
situation
uh was toxic
yes sir
were you there
and did you personally see the police
come
numerous times to the property
yes sir i did
and were you
present
during any of those times yes sir it
at any was
during those times did did you hear
michael barrisson tell the police that
he was objectionable
mr blencus
sustained
no
not again it's the same ruling i had
before
it's hearsay
yes it is
all right so you were present when
the police arrived yes sir
and you saw of the police talking
to michael barriston correct yes sir
um
were you present when
mary haskins sent her child away
yes sir was
and was that emotional for her yes sir
do you know when that occurred ma'am
what day after you arrived you said you
arrived on a friday
but i'm sorry all right but it was
during the time from
the second to when the uh the incident
happened
between when i got there on friday uh
probably over that weekend because i had
intended just to come for the weekend
and because things continued to get
worse and worse and more tense and
uh michael asked me to stay
all right and so i stayed
but in this is a young child
who
did not need to be in that environment
and that situation at all
and so mh made arrangements
for him to leave and to go to her mother
very good thank you
now
were you present when the town officials
came to the property
and kicked everyone out of
the stable area yes sir was
and from that point on was
michael barissone sleeping outside
on the porch on the mattress
yes sir
now
was there
ever a time while you were there
where you were with michael barrasson
and
you saw lauren cataract
night
in the woods
flashing a flashlight on and off
i was there when michael and i were on
the front porch and somewhat saw someone
out in the field
with a flashlight
putting it on and off and on and off
whether it was her or not
i cannot tell you
did you ever
see
lauren cataract and rob goodwin come to
this stable area
and
after hours
and turn all the lights on and start
playing the music loudly
yes sir absolutely did that was why i
was asked by michael
to
spend the nights in front of our horse
don devone we called him affectionately
d.d
because she would cunt she and he would
come at odd hours during the night and
do exactly as you said turn all the
lights on in the stable turn on the
music
uh which
in for the horses they should have quiet
and peace at night and not be disturbed
because they are very busy during the
day
and um
that was that was the routine that was
asked to be done at the stables is after
eight o'clock that there'd be nobody up
there in the stables and
is it safe to say based on your
observations that lauren canarek
refused to abide by those rules
absolutely sir she did
now
let's talk about this course dede
you indicated that michael was concerned
for the safety of that horse on direct
correct yes sir um
were you also concerned yes sir i was
concerned as well
how how much is dd worth
approximately
are you asking me how much he was worth
then or how much he might be worth now
i would assume that
what now
then then yes not now just then at the
time
um
i would have said he was worth 200.
excuse me i would have said i would have
said he was worth probably around two
hundred thousand dollars
with the potential to be worth a lot
more correct yes sir and that's why i
asked the question
do you want me to tell you something now
now
this conversation that you've uh
testified to
with regards to the gun
that was in front of dd's stall correct
yes sir now
isn't lauren canorax locker
right nearby there
i couldn't tell you sir i have no idea
about that i don't know where her locker
was
um
did you receive any information with
regards to the
possible recording
of private conversations in the
stable area don't answer that question
i think he calls for a hearsay answer
doesn't it mr malinkas
unless she unless she has personal
knowledge herself somehow but
other than that it would be a hearsay
answer
were you concerned about
your private conversations being
recorded
at any time
yes sir
do you have any idea where
any recordings were placed
in the stable area
no sir i do not
now
this conversation with regards to your
uh
your gun
uh it was in your vehicle correct yes
sir
and and at the time of that conversation
uh would you agree with me that things
were going crazy at the stable uh or on
the property
yes
um did michael barrasson ever
discuss with you a concern of people
going into your truck
yeah
mr blinkis those are all hearsay answers
they're all objectionable
all right my ruling stands mr balancas
that conversation with regards to the
gun
occurred
right in front of bd stall correct yes
sir and
um you indicated that
you were
sleeping
there yes sir
was that a common thing for you to do
when you visited the farm
sleeping in front of my horse's stable
yeah no sir that was not common
i was asked to do that
by michael because of his concern
for the horse
on any previous occasion that you have
come to the farm
have you ever slept
in front of your horse's stall no sir
now
with regards to that
course was there an incident
with you and lauren canarac
regarding the feeding of that horse
yes sir
um
during this time
did lauren
i'm not sure what the relevance of this
line of questioning is
okay
all right sorry for that delay ladies
and gentlemen
there are a number of legal issues that
uh come up during testimony as you have
seen that have to be resolved outside of
your presence
again i'll try to keep them at a minimum
but it is important to get that decision
right
all right the objections overruled you
can ask the question mr blancas
dr cox
you indicated that
lauren cataract is
coming to the stable after hours right
yes sir
and
that was against
the rule
yes sir
and
on one of those occasions
when all this stuff is going on
did she attempt
to feed your animal yes sir
was that after you told her not to feed
your animal
yes sir it was after she had fed him
and i asked her to please please do not
feed him
and
she did it again
she was feeding him some sugar
lumps of sugar
and were you concerned
in light of everything that was going on
her
feeding
your horse yes sir i was very concerned
and
was she videotaping this
or were you trying to videotape this
yes i did videotape it
and why did you videotape it
because of my concern
for the horse and what was going on with
the horse
did you communicate that to mr barrison
did i tell him that this had happened
yes yes sir i did when did that happen
when did i tell him yes if you recall
it would have been the next time that i
saw him what thank you
ladies and gentlemen um you did hear
some testimony regarding some
uh alleged conduct of miss canorac
that conduct was admitted only uh for a
limited purpose
it's not bad character evidence against
miss cataract that's not the purpose of
the testimony the relevance of the
testimony is only whether mr barrissone
learned about it and whether or not it
affected his state of mind in any way
alright that's the only purpose the
court allowed that testimony
in court today it's not meant to be
testimony or evidence about the bad
character of miss cataract all right
very good thank you go ahead mr valencus
now
testified on direct with a with regards
to a meeting with an attorney
that you were present at correct yes sir
and
i don't want you to say what was
discussed
but as a result of that
we're
that
after that meeting with the attorney
did
um
lauren cataract
come to the stable area
later that day
i did not know how to answer that
question because there were several
meetings with his attorney
so
you'd have to
i don't know how to answer that question
i don't know what day you're talking
about every freezer okay
um
this sport is a dangerous sport correct
yes sir it is and
um
it's common for people to sign releases
uh in case
they're injured
okay i know what day you're talking
about now if that's what you're talking
about okay
so
you had a lawyer with the meeting you
had a meeting with the lawyer on that
day correct
and
did lauren cataract come to the stables
later that day yes sir she did and and
was there a discussion with regards to
her signing and release yes sir
and
was rob goodwin there he was
and uh
they basically refused correct yes sir
michael garrison was there correct yes
sir
i was standing beside him was was
michael barrasson calm
when he was talking to them absolutely
and can you describe
how
robert goodwin was
he was a bit excitable about that
he
you want me to continue to explain it
um he obviously did not like the
situation he made some threatening uh
remarks to michael he also threatened me
robert goodwood threatened you yes sir
what did he say to you uh he had already
made something to object
it's hearsay
well well you didn't ask about that she
just said no no no but you didn't your
follow-up question was not about that
right that's why it's objectionable
with all due respect to dr cox her state
of mind is not an issue in this case
mr barris owns this
so if you want to if you want to
rephrase
and ask about
any threat that was made to mr barrisone
that may be permissible
dr cox
did robert goodwin
threaten michael barisson on that day
yes what specifically did he tell him
i do not remember the specific words but
it was around
uh he was not going to
let let michael determine what was going
on with him and
his girlfriend's horses
she answered the question
i'm going to show her her transcript and
answer it refreshes her recollection as
to the exact words she she didn't say
she needed her memory refreshed
she just answered the question
if i may i'd like to give her the
transcript have her look at her
statement she says she doesn't remember
the exact words
i want to show her statement ask her if
it refreshes her recollection with
regards to the exact words
i'll allow it
with regard to the exact words
what's the exhibit number
uh it appears to be 500-5a
dr cox i'm going to show you
505k
do you remember giving a uh
a statement
on august 7th
to the morris county prosecutor's office
yes sir did
can you please turn to
page 31
okay
lines 3
through 5.
and ask you that refreshes your
recollection with regards to
what the exact words
concerning the threat to michael plus
just just read it to yourself doctor
i have read it sir
does that refresh your recollection
that's exactly it sir
what is exactly it you want me to read
what this says i want you to testify to
what
the exact threat was to michael barrasso
to get that refreshed directly okay
you know i don't think she should read
it if she's saying that her recollection
has been refreshed to the exact words
then she can do it for memory that was
the whole point of this exercise
does that refresh your memory without
without reading it it's it's to
refresh your memory dr cox that
transcript refreshes my mind now just
testify if you can without reading
specifically what's in your prior
statement okay
he he said
again he said to michael with you doing
the kind of stuff that you're doing
he said so the record is clear judge the
witness is reading from the transcript
right it hasn't been removed
i understand i'll allow it in this one
instance
he said i will take you down
thank you
now
you were present when the uh the town
came
and kicked everyone out of the stable
correct yes sir was
no
were you asked to
go to the farmhouse
at any point
yes sir was and why were you asked to go
to the farmhouse as opposed to michael
well hold on a sec
just yes or no no
but still
we don't know anything about who told
her that or why why she was told it
calls for a hearsay answer
on the day the town came
did you go to the farmhouse
with somebody yes
and did you go inside
yes sir
and were you attacked by cataract storm
yes sir
what's the relevance to that
the dog attacked michael barrasso
i haven't heard that i haven't wait a
second i haven't first of all i haven't
heard that yet
while it may
have some relevance to the defendant
what is the relevance
to the dog
unfortunately biting doctor cox or toxic
attacking the doctor
there's no relevance to that here the
police officer judge testified that the
dog
but mr belinkus you're missing the point
i don't see how that is remotely
relevant
now
when you gave michael barristone
that gun
isn't it a fact
that both magazines had bullets in them
not to my knowledge that's not a fact
if i can approach again judge i'm going
to show you
again your transcript d505a
which
was a statement you gave
the day of the incident
can you
turn to page 23.
line 25
can you read that to
yourself and tell me whether it
refreshes your recollection
as to whether or not
there were bullets in the magazines
plural
yes it does it refreshes my brain where
the bullets in the magazines
i'm i'm hesitant with with how to answer
that question
if you're asking me if both magazines
were full of bullets
is that what you're asking me you don't
recall one way or the other do you no
sir i don't would you agree with me that
on the seventh you indicated that they
were correct
on the seventh what my answer would be
that i know that one
am i answering this all right
you looked at me i thought maybe no i'm
just no
i would tell you if i wanted you to be
worried okay well i just didn't want to
do anything wrong here so i would i
would tell you that that my recall is
that one magazine was full the other
magazine probably had several bullets in
it i cannot tell you
that both magazines were full of bullets
and that has been my hesitancy to answer
your question i don't know if i've made
it worse or better in what i've said
okay based on what you say would you
agree with me you're not a hundred
percent sure
as to how many bullets were in each
magazine
that is an absolute correct statement
sir thank you first for me okay well i'm
glad i was part of it
[Laughter]
okay now
on the day of the incident
were you asked to
stand guard and watch things prior to
dcp deif is coming
ask me that question again were you
asked to
come and stand guard or watch over
things
before
typhus came
who is that
oh that's the child protective service
no sir i was not asked that
nothing further jeff
all right thank you any redirect no
thank you judge
all right dr cox you're all finished
you may go i'm excused yes you are thank
you please don't discuss the case with
anyone though yes okay thank you so very
much nice seeing you again
foreign ex-witness judge of state calls
vanessa medrano cortes
yes hi man good
oh
morning
i need you to be sworn so place your
left you can put your jacket down on the
chair for a moment
left hand on the bible
please raise your right hand and listen
to my court clerk who will administer
the
of almighty oath that the testimony
gives to this court regarding this
matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth yes
please state your name your last name
for the record vanessa
medrano cortes
m-e-d r-a-n-o hyphen c-o-r-t-e-z
thank you
thank you man you may have a seat
thank you
please keep your voice up nice and loud
and responsive questions if you don't
understand the question it's okay to
indicate that you don't understand i'll
have counsel rephrase the question
that's something that you don't
understand okay all right very good
mr sheldon
thank you
good morning mr john cortez good morning
can you please uh reintroduce yourself
to the jury and tell them how old you
are yes i am vanessa madrano protests
and i'm currently 29 years old where do
you work
for the division of child protection and
permanency approximately how long have
you worked for that agency
for about six years and a half can you
tell the jury
briefly what the responsibilities of the
division are
so i am an intake role and in the intake
unit where we receive reports of child
abuse or neglect
and were you in that same position in
august of 2019 yes
what are your general day-to-day
responsibilities as a member of the
intake unit so i receive reports with
allegations of abuse or neglect and my
job is to respond to
the house
address that is on the report to
investigate if there is actual
abuse or neglect
were you in the same or substantially
the same role in august of 2019 yes
how are some of the ways that the
division can be notified or referred of
a case like you just talked about
an individual could call
the sdr which is the state central
registry
and report concerns or an incident of
abuse or neglect to a child
are there other uh
entities that are mandatory reporting
agencies
or mandatory reporters
yes it could be
police departments
teachers
medical staff
anybody as a case worker how were you
assigned your cases
um we go based on a rotation list of
about 15 people and whoever's next
receives the next case
what determines uh the response time for
when you would respond to investigate
so there are two types of referrals one
is the child protective services
referral the other one is
child welfare assessment the child
protective services referral actually
has allegations of abuse or neglect
to be investigated and with the child
welfare services referral we assess for
services for the family in order to
bring stability or any help they may
need as well
with respect to a child protective
services for abuse or neglect are there
different categories of response time
yes there is a 24-hour response and also
an immediate response
in your experience does the referral
typically include
an alleged perpetrator
on the child protective services
referral yes what is an alleged
perpetrator someone who is being accused
of the
act whether it is abuse or neglect force
a child
when you're assigned a case can you tell
the jury what the steps you take are to
begin your investigation yeah so i do re
i called a reporter um to find out more
information
about the allegations of abuse or
neglect and then i proceed to the home
unannounced
an interview sorry interview everyone
privately
do you review the uh screening summary
yes can you tell the jury what the
screening summary is the screening
summary is a report where um it gives
the details of
the incident that happened with concerns
of abuse or neglect
now you indicated that there are two
types of referrals abuse or neglect what
are some examples of abuse
so with the views um some examples could
be emotional abuse sexual abuse physical
abuse
among those
and with
respect to neglect what are some
examples of neglect with neglect
it could be substance abuse
inadequate supervision
not enough
food in the home
now do you recall being assigned a
referral on tuesday august 6th regarding
the address of 411 west mill road in
washington township yes
do you know why you were assigned that
referral
i was next on rotation and it was a
child protective services referral with
allegations of neglect
and i'll ask you some questions about
the referral uh do you recall who the
alleged perpetrator was
yes mary gorganis
do you recall whether it involved child
abuse or neglect
objection judge i'm not going to be able
to get into the specifics
all right objections overwhelmed with my
limiting instructions
go ahead mr shellhorn
cortez uh
i was asking you some questions about
the general nature of the referral
and i think you were indicating that
that uh referral in involved uh
complaint of neglect
yes
and was the response time there listed
for 24 hours yes are you aware that the
reporter of that was safe sport
yes
now based on the information that you
learned from
reviewing the referral and the screening
summary
what was your response plan
i went out and announced to the home
took a state vehicle with me
and my plan was to interview everyone
privately
did you also know the name from the
referral of michael barrison
yes he was listed as a household member
do you recall if an individual named
lauren canaric was listed at all in that
report i don't recall
now on august 7 2019 did you arrive to
411 west mill in in the minivan
yes and you recall whether you were by
yourself or with anyone else i was by
myself
were you made aware of any safety
concerns no
if you were would that have changed your
response
yes
were you there looking specifically for
michael bearson
no
when you arrived at the address do you
remember approximately or the general
area where you went on the property
um i went towards the barn
all the way down the driveway i will
call it
and parked on the left side of the barn
it's in the front
now i'm going to judge if i could have
permission to show
three exhibits that are already in
evidence 301 302
and 312.
yes
they may be shown to the witness
up on the screen
approximately what time of day was it
when you arrived to the
it was in the afternoon maybe
1 1 130.
so i recognize uh that s 312 is a
picture in the dark but aside from that
what do you recognize s312 today
uh the barn
the main entrance of the barn
and is that the same barn that you
recall going on august 7 2019 yes when
you arrived to the property and you were
in this area did you park in the parking
lot yes do you see the area where you
parked on this picture yes on the left
side by the black car
when you got uh did you get out of your
car
um
no i parked and a male came towards me i
didn't know
it was michael barrison then
but um
i left the band and that's when he
introduced himself
did you tell him where you were yes and
what else did you tell him
very vaguely that we had a ref i had a
referral from child protective services
did you get into any specifics about the
referral no why not
because i discussed the details of the
referral individually and privately
and is that your common practice and
your habit yes
when you told him who you were and where
you were there from
uh what did you do next
um he called miss
garganus she came outside of the door
and
she allowed me to go inside the office
of the barn
do you recall
when you did you go in that door that we
see on s312 yes and you recall which
direction you went when you went inside
the door towards the left
and i'm going to show you a picture
that's entered into evidence as s-301
what do you recognize s-301 today
the office
and does that appear to be the same uh
or substantially the same condition that
the office was in when you met with uh
mr danis
uh mostly yes except the chair of
positions
and just so the record is clear are you
aware of whether mr ganes had another
last name or went by another last name
at times
i wasn't aware when i arrived
and are you aware now that she also has
the last name of gray
yes
now s 301 is a picture of the office
that you indicated that you met uh with
and i'll call her miss gray because
that's how we've been referring to her
so i apologize if that's somewhat
confusing
uh that's the office that you met with
miss graham yes
and when you met with her in that office
was anyone else present with you
no
was the door open or closed
the door was closed
and you recall if you were sitting
standing or something else i was sitting
how about me
miss gray was sitting towards the window
now just without getting into any of the
details now
did you tell her any more specific
details about why you were there yes i
discussed the details of the report with
her
do you remember approximately how long
you spoke with her
for about 30 minutes
during the course of time that you were
meeting with miss gray in this office
with the door closed did anyone
interrupt you
yes mr barrison came to the office about
three times
what did you tell him uh the first time
that he interrupted you
that i needed to speak with her
privately first
what did you tell him the second time
that he interrupted
i'm sure you're safe
how was it here say
what she told michael paris
i'll ask you a question again yes um so
my question was what did you tell him
the second time that he interrupted you
he asked me if we were almost done and
and i said
that we weren't done yet a couple more
minutes
uh on the third time that he interrupted
you did he say anything to you and mrs
gray
he said that he needed the office i had
told him that
i was almost done with releases
the person always needs to sign releases
um
so yeah he said he needed the office and
after he told you and ms gray that he
needed the office did you stay there or
before leave we moved to the next room
had you ever met mr garzon before that
day no do you recall what his appearance
or demeanor was
he appeared to be
confused
somewhat upset
did you see him running around at all
no i was in the office at all times
when you were in the room or had any
interaction with him did you hear him
yelling
no
do you recall whether there was a safe
inside of that office
yes
and i'm going to show you what's been
marked
and entered into evidence as s-302 do
you see the safe in this picture yes can
you tell the jury where it is
on the right side of the picture
with the wall
did you see whether or not anyone went
into that state
um miss gray
retrieved documents from the safe
to show me
and do you recall who opened the sig
no
directing your attention back to the
third time that the defendant
interrupted you and ms gray
do you recall anything specific about
what he did when he interrupted on that
third occasion
um as we were leaving the office he
grabbed her arm and kissed her
he grabbed ms gray's arm and kissed her
yes kissed her on the cheek
as i was in the middle of both of them
did you see the defendant again
no
were you still at the property of 411
west hill road when the police arrived
yes
do you have any personal or direct
knowledge of what happened elsewhere on
the the property that day no
just two more questions ms majorano
cortez uh based on what happened was the
case transferred to another caseworker
yes
and did that caseworker complete any
follow-up or investigation and prepare
any reports yes
judge no further questions thank you all
right cross-examination
no questions
all right you may step down man thanks
judge i know it's probably a little
early for our morning break but i do
want to check and make sure the next
witness is here and i expect that that
witness will will certainly take us
through the rest of the morning
all right um
this is a little you want a break now if
we could break now then i think we could
push through
all right we'll break now 20 minutes
ladies and gentlemen and then um we'll
work through
until lunch with the next witness thank
you
[Music]
so
all right we'll take 20 minutes
[Music]
by
cataract with regards to her civil
lawsuit
and were provided
i don't intend to bring out the
circumstances of why she had the photos
taken judge just that they do depict the
injuries that she sustained
with respect to s386
my understanding of that
incision was that the bleeding was
excessive inside her body and it was uh
she was cut open to relieve the pressure
and with respect to s 385
that's the
again the incision that then continues
around
to her back
where during the
emergent operation she was opened up in
order for the doctors to
perform perform surgery
all right
i'm going to disallow the use of these
photographs 385 386
387
i don't think they're necessary in this
case
388 will be allowed that shows
um a front view of miss canorack
just above
the left breast which
shows
two entry wounds
i also understand we've had testimony
about the gunshot wounds to the victim
and the perforations as well as the exit
wounds to the back
and as i understand it the treating
physician or the doctor who performed
the surgery
will testify and can certainly testify
about
miss cataract's medical condition the
bullet wounds the path of the wounds the
exit wounds
the need for the incision in the stomach
and
all such medical related information
these pictures are
after the fact at some point i don't i
don't know exactly when
um
and i'm not sure the
incisions are necessary for any
determination by the jury here
and there's no
issue
that miss canorack was shot in this case
so i don't think those are necessary for
um
in this state to meet their burden here
but certainly any testimony regarding
the injuries is fine and other
photographs agreed to which show the
entrance
wounds
can be admitted but not those
385 386 387.
judge then with that i would ask that
the court receive into evidence and if
we could just do this
while we're on the topic of s 388 that
could be received into evidence so i can
show it to the
witness
uh as well as and and
by the the witness can certainly testify
about her injuries
yes sorry and in addition i'm not
foreclosing that it's just the the
photographs of the incisions i don't
think are necessary and
and judge if i could also ask to admit
into evidence at this point
s three three five
s three four two
s three four three all right let's start
start over again three a eight is in
what are the other ones s335
s342
s343
s345
all right those are photographs of
the farmhouse
yesterday right outside exterior yes
location of uh the shooting incident
one of them is a photo of the front of
the farmhouse
but the others depict the exterior of
the farmhouse in the area okay
any objection
all right
those are in evidence
are we ready for the jury
i bring the jury in miss raddler
hey mr shellhorn mister i know mr
canarack was here he's been told
yes judge
he's not here
judge we also i just discussed with mr
balinkis
two
pages from the facebook to facebook
records
there's a stipulation to the
authenticity of those okay those are
marked as s 400
400
i apologize s402
and then i had marked two pages uh as
s402a
and s402b
that i made sure to witness i have shown
those to mr belinkus
uh
all right the jurors are present be
seated
ladies and gentlemen during the break it
uh we did have some legal discussions um
about a number of things but focused on
some photographs so rather than do that
in front of you we did it outside of
your presence
for the next witness so the court did
admit the following photographs into
evidence and they'll be likely shown to
the next witness so it's
states exhibit 335.
that's a photograph 342
343
345
and
finally 388
so those have all been reviewed by
council they have agreed that those can
be admitted into evidence and the court
has so admitted those photographs so
we're ready to proceed with the next
witness mr shalhon call your next
witness please if you're under the state
calls warren kenner lauren canorack
hi miss counteract please remain
standing uh place your left hand on the
bible if you would please uh raise your
right hand
thank you listen to my court clerk do
you swing the presence of almighty god
that the testimony gives to this quote
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
i do please stationary muslia last name
for the record
lauren shea
kenorak
last name spelled k a
and is nancy a
r e k
thank you all right miss kind eric you
may have a seat
in response to questions please keep
your voice up nice and loud that
microphone does not amplify
it only records so we have jurors seated
in the first two rows of the gallery as
well as in the jury box so keep your
voice up nice and loud if you don't
understand a question just indicate you
don't understand and i'll have counsel
rephrase and if you hear during your
testimony uh one of the attorneys object
please uh don't answer or stop answering
until the court rules on the objection
all right very good thank you all right
go ahead mr sheldon thank your honor
good morning ms canteraff can you please
introduce yourself again to the jury yes
my name is lauren kenrick
and that actually doesn't amplify at all
it just picks up so you don't have to
lean in don't worry about that uh how
old are you i am 41. where do you
currently live
i currently live in florida welling in
loxahatchee florida
do you know michael barrison i do do you
see him in court today i do can you
identify him for the record by an
article of clothing that he's wearing um
yes
he is wearing a white shirt and a
yellowish tie what
identifying the defendant mr barristone
for the record
before we get to how you know the
defendant i want to ask you some
questions about your background in the
equestrian world can you tell the jury a
little bit about what your equestrian
background is starting with what your
current writing discipline is
my current writing discipline is
dressage can you explain to the jury
what dressage is
as best as possible
um
dressage
literally transfers to frank to training
in front in french
but what essentially is
supposed to be is
a harmonious partnership between horse
and rider
in competition
it is to execute a series of movements
that is judged on
technicalities
um and in training
you could just be riding your horse
trying to build a better partnership
so you have a good relationship with
your horse
and things are just done harmoniously
have you ever written any other
disciplines i have can you tell the jury
what that was i used to do
show jumping or jumping
and not just basically i'm riding around
a course of jumps
at different heights and
at our high speeds try to get it done
quickly do you recall when you switched
from focusing on jumping to dressage
yes sometime around
2015
i want to say around that area what was
the reason that you switched the
discipline that you were focusing on
i was just kind of a little bit bored
i've been jumping since i was a
very young teenager and i just
saw people riding
in the disciplined dressage and thought
this looks more fun
some people might see it as boring but i
thought
this looks fun i want to try it it's
interesting and that's what i did
in general what is the process that a
writer would go through in terms of
developing that harmonious relationship
with the horse
um
well
you would hire hopefully a trainer to
help you
try to move those things along
um
[Music]
you could
spend a lot of time doing ground work
riding is the main thing riding's kind
of a must there
um
[Music]
but yes i would say the combination of
things you do on your own with your
horse and
things that you would do with a trainer
to help you get better at what you're
doing with your horse to
make that relationship better and what
specifically are the things that a
trainer helps the rider or the horse
develop during that process
um
a variety of different skills
um
a trainer might help a horse develop
a certain movement that you might
uh show in a test that you're competing
in
um
but
yeah that's exactly what i would say
where do horses typically live
in a stable barn stall
and is it common to train at the same
facility where the horses are boarded
yes
does the same person typically coach the
rider as well as the horses
yes
taking your attention back to 2018 and
2019 who was your trainer
2008 i'm sorry can you repeat the
question we're taking you back to 2018
and 2019 who was your trainer
michael barcelona
uh did you pay him to to train you yes
and did you pay him to board the horses
yes
do you remember approximately how much
he was paid monthly uh in let's call it
the summer of 2019. approximately five
thousand dollars
a month
now you said that you currently live in
loxahatchee florida yes oh have you ever
lived in new jersey i have when was that
um
i guess from the age of four until
somewhere around
2000
have you ever lived in new jersey
after the year 2000
even on a uh seasonal basis uh yeah
when you came back uh to new jersey
where would you live um
specifically in 2018 and 2009 i would
live on the premises of haw thornhill
farm in a farmhouse
where is hawthorne hill farm it is
located in long valley new jersey
whose form was that
michael barcelona
at times during the year is it common
for
specifically dressage riders to train in
different parts of the country
yes what's the reason for that
mainly the weather
but um aside from that
um you go to i guess when you're riding
at the levels that you want to be riding
at their higher levels
you go to florida because that's kind of
like the mecca of
i guess
dressage and jumping in the entire
country that's where that's where
everything is located the top trainers
top clinic uh clinics
events um you know
things to go out and do so that's where
you go for the winter you like or
snowbird kind of
that's how that works
now uh speaking of that uh
do you recall when you first met michael
barrison
um yes i met him
either at the very end
of february or very beginning of march
of 2018. do you recall where you met him
yes i met him at
his barn
in loxahatchee florida
yes yes
and what was the
purpose for you being at his barn at
that time period um he was giving a
clinic that month
so i attended it with my trainer that
was training me at the time
at the time when you went to that clinic
were you familiar with him by either
name or reputation um
by name
as a clinician mostly
and after meeting him and
participating in that clinic
did you become involved in a
professional relationship with him yes
what was the nature of that professional
relationship you entered into in early
2018
um that
he was basically the trainer of my
horses
and
um
like
while he was holding the clinic
no so uh you said that he would train
your horses yes uh were there was there
any other
things that you agreed with him that he
would do for you or that you would do
for him
oh yeah well he was
during that clinic
um
he was saying to me i need to come to
new jersey
and train there
so and he was like you know pushing this
and
he seemed to
be an excellent trainer i thought
that's probably a good idea
now what
what are your aspirations within the
dressage community
just to be the best rider that i can be
and develop my horses to the top levels
of the sport
and is having a trainer
important to that goal
extremely important that goal
during the course of time that you
worked with the defendant
uh how would you
how would you say that your riding
went
very well i improved greatly in a short
period of time i was very satisfied
[Music]
did you have the opportunity to train at
the florida farm as well as the new
jersey farm yes both
now i'll point your attention again to
2018 and 2019 during the summer season
when you i think indicated you were
training at hawthorne hill in new jersey
yes
where did you live
when you were here in new jersey
training i lived for the first year
um in the farmhouse on the property
on
the main entrance floor
and did you live in a different place
during the second summer yes where was
that that was in a different apartment
within that same home
in the upstairs apartment of that same
house just a different floor different
apartment
based on your recollection then the
hawthorne hill farm had living
accommodations for people as well as
boarding accommodations for horses
correct
is that common for a rider to live at
the same property where they're training
um yeah it happens
it's
common can you tell the jury a little
bit about uh your impressions or your
recollections about what else was on the
property
you mean as far as um like
barnes or
was there a place was there a stable was
there training arenas or facilities yeah
okay so
there was the farmhouse where people
lived and then there's also
like a very large barn
with an arena
um indoor arena and there's also
an outdoor arena
um
what we call a round pen for training
um and also a clubhouse for like
gatherings
just kind of hang out in between rides
and things like that like a little
social area so that was also on the
property
is it fair to say that when you were on
the property or when you had horses
there would you spend a good deal of
time up at the barn or the uh the
clubhouse
yes i was up there riding yeah
i would say that's fair say
do you recall in specifically uh
in that building the area between
the stables where the horse's stalls
were and the clubhouse yes what was in
that area
lockers
um
specifically in between the clubhouse
and where the stalls are yes um the road
lockers and
i believe two tack rooms where you'd
store saddles and larger pieces of
equipment
did you have a locker in that area yes i
did
judge i'd like to uh
show the witness
one of the photos that's already been
moved into evidence this is s 329
very well
can be displayed on the screen
this can rack is that the hallway that
you're talking about that leads from the
stables into the clubhouse yes it is
what's through that door on the left
there
so through the store um you can kind of
see that they're
saddles that are on racks
um which is yeah that's mostly all a
saddle rock row
and
to the right of the uh
door hanging on the wall what are all
those things
these are
awards and
medals different medallions and
different things that you might win if
let's say
you've won a show or you've competed at
a certain level
usdf or uscf the federations which
oversee our sport
might send them to you or you might win
them win them at the show
at the very show itself
did you have any uh awards or medallions
on that wall
um
not on this wall but sort of right next
to it
at one point
not at this in this picture but but as
part of this uh collection of medals yes
yes
thanks alex
all right i want to go back and ask you
some questions about the living
arrangements on the uh
the property you indicated that the
first summer you were there in 2018
that you were there and you lived on the
first floor of the farmhouse correct can
you describe for the jury what the
general
layout or or makeup of the farmhouse was
sure
um so
the farmhouse had basically
three floors
um
the main floor
um
had a bedroom
and like a kitchen
the and of course the bathroom
the basement had several bedrooms for
staff to stay and they had their own
rooms
and
everyone kind of lived together in the
upstairs upstairs apartment as well
where the assistant trainer lived
so
there was altogether
three living spaces but one of which had
several different bedrooms for a group
of people to stay
kind of like a you know a sorority a
little bit house in a way
is that where the the working students
would live yes
uh was the
was the farmhouse
or were all these separate areas in the
farmhouse interconnected
by some method or another yes like there
was a way you could get to each floor
but they weren't just like completely
closed off
when you moved there in the summer of
2018 the first summer you lived there on
the first floor did you live there with
anyone
yes who did you live there with i lived
there with my boyfriend or fiance my
partner like partner and my two dogs
and what is his name robert goodwin
judge i'd like to show
the witness a uh exhibit s402b
that's one we haven't discussed that's
one we discussed right before the jury
came in your honor
there's a stipulation as to the
authenticity of the uh
the records that these came
all right from well
402 b it is yes on 402 b
miss carrick do you uh have a facebook
account i do um and how would you rate
your facebook activity how with what
frequency do you use facebook
quite a lot
at least at the time
and i'm going to draw you
i'm going to draw your attention to a
post from may 13 2018
and this has been marked as s402
b
[Music]
what is s402b a picture of
oh
my dog
is in the picture where is this picture
taken
this is taken in the main floor
apartment
of the farmhouse of the farm house yes
and uh can you point out where the dog
is in that picture
now i can um
wait how do i or you could just explain
it to the jury they have it on the big
screen um
so she is
you see the chair that's kind of like
tucked into the table
if you look
back and to the left of that there's
like a like a dark figure
sitting with like her head facing
rightwards
um that's the dog
so that's through the doorway in the
other room yes to go into the living
room what's her name
rosie
you know what approximately how
big rosie is
she's approximately
28 pounds
um short
uh so you indicated that in the summer
of 2018
you and rob and your dogs were living on
the first floor of the farmhouse correct
working students were living downstairs
yes and the assistant trainer was living
on the second floor
uh yeah
i guess depending on how you count the
basement but yes the top floor the
second second or third depending
what is uh the assistant trainer's name
justin hardin
now what were the circumstances uh of
your coming to live in the farmhouse
that summer of 2018
the circumstances were that
um
we were at the clinic in florida
michael
basically had said you know
come to new jersey with me
i will help you develop these horses
um
you know come i have a place here to
stay
that will not be a problem
just just
load your horses come your
will have a combination for you to stay
and to rent anything outside the area of
the barn you'll love it and i was sold
immediately
did your living situation at the farm uh
change between 2018 and when you came
back there for the summer of 2019 it did
where did you live in the summer
of 2019
in the summer of 2019 upon our turn to
new jersey
um we were living in that upstairs
apartment
instead of the main floor that we just
saw a picture of someone want to go and
just specifically from what you knew
when you came back to the farmhouse that
summer of 2019 did you have a chance to
see
uh the condition of the rest of the
farmhouse
well i'm sorry i'm so sorry could you
repeat that one one time sure when you
came back to the farmhouse in 2019 that
summer did you have a chance to see the
condition of the other levels of the
farmhouse
yes
um and what did you see or what did you
observe of those levels
um
[Music]
the levels that were below
the level that we were staying in
were
pretty much like just like almost
unlivable pretty much destroyed
um from a pipe that had burst previously
now during the summer of 2019 when you
lived there and you were on the top
floor
was any of the working students living
in the bottom floor no do you know where
they were living um they were all sent
to go live in the barn somewhere
was anyone living at times on the first
floor or the main floor of the farmhouse
um yes um we returned
of mary haskins gray
and michael barazone were living in
the main floor and the basement of that
house and i don't think i've asked you
yet but uh who is mary haskins greg
mary haskins gray is michael verson's
girlfriend
was she his girlfriend during the entire
course of time that you knew the
defendant
yes
did you know before you came back to new
jersey in 2019 that you would be living
on the top floor of the farmhouse
i'm sorry just i wasn't sure about the
dates there could you just repeat that
one time i'm sorry did you know before
you came back to new jersey in 2019 that
you would be living on a different floor
of the farmhouse
i did what was the circumstances of you
going to live on the second floor
the circumstances were that
the house was unlivable
um
and that there was
really only one place that was livable
and that would be the upstairs apartment
although that was the assistant trainers
department so
we ended up working out some situation
where it ended up being that we were
able to live on the top floor and
michael said he'd work everything else
out so we just went with that
and just so the record is clear when you
say we were able to work that out who do
you mean you worked that out with me
myself and michael barrison
questions about the boarding and
training arrangements that you had
with your horses
how many horses did you own in 2019
in 2019 i owned
i owned six horses at that time
and what are the reasons that you own
six horses
i like horses
um but also um
i feel it's important and
michael would always you know say this
is important as a trainer um to keep
horses on the same levels some of them
um so if you're competing
you can
let's say if you like make a team or
um
get selected to go to regionals as a
pair
you and a horse get your horse goes lame
you then have the option
to
ride and get those scores
with the nut with the same another horse
that's at the same level so it's
important to keep some horses at the
same levels doing the same things
but it's also important to have horses
at a different level to
learn how to bring them up the levels on
your own
to build that harmony i was talking
about earlier
were all of your horses at
the defendant's farm when you were there
in the summer of 2019 no
did you have horses at other
farms yes
do you recall how many horses you had at
the farm in 2019
i
um so 20
it was different
amounts of different times in 2019.
i had
four
horses one of which i purchased from him
and
yeah that's i had four on the premise on
his premises at that time
judge can we have a more specific
timeframe different times
judge i'm sure that's something that mr
bolinkis is free to clear up on
cross-examination if he thinks it's
important
well you can do that mr balancas
now you talked about the importance of
having a a trainer to train with uh
the rider and the horse
what is the what is the breakdown what's
the responsibility of the rider versus
the trainer
during the course of that training
it changes
um
i would say
it's the responsibility of the rider
because you're the one who needs to get
the job done at the end of the day
the trainer
the more experienced the trainer is
should be on the ground and should be
somebody that can spot a mistake
immediately
and try to help you fix it
and if you are unable to fix it
a trainer will usually get on the horse
and see
what is the trainer what is he or she
feeling
that
you know you're not able to figure out
on your own and they might have
different ways of fixing the problem
before you get on and try to do it
yourself again
and specifically with respect to your
training with michael barrasson
did you have the opportunity to work
with him training on occasion yes
and i think you said that you became a
better rider with him as your coach and
trainer definitely
now you indicated that uh justin hardin
was an assistant trainer correct what
were your impressions or observations of
his general responsibilities at the
farms
um
my observations were that he would
sometimes assist in training
um and also basically i guess delegate
responsibilities to what he would
consider to be
you know the the less
less senior members of the staff or
whatever
however you might raise that for lack of
a better phrase
now at times during the course of uh
when you
first became associated with michael
garzon in early march or early 2018
yes um through into 2019
were you coached at times
by michael barissone and justin hart yes
were there any times where you were
coached or trained by mary haskins grad
during that time specifically or the
whole time during the entire time uh yes
there
and how did you feel about that
i wasn't very excited about that can you
explain why
to me i did not feel she had the
experience
the training
or any of the things that uh like a
higher level trainer would possess that
i did and or it could just be that you
know
you don't mesh with the person but to me
i didn't feel she had the experience
did she play any role in your decision
to switch your trainer in 2018 and go
train with michael verasa
in other words did you go train with
michael barasone because of mary haskins
gray
no why did you go train with michael
garrison
because he was a trainer with more
experience and he basically
was the person that had been there and
done that
um
so they're never feeling any issue of
you know like competition someone's
already been
to the highest places they're trying to
help you get better
now did you compete in any uh
competitions or attend any horse shows
during the period of time that you were
associated with michael barrison's
business yes
what is his
uh business considered in the dressage
industry
training business what kind of a barn is
it it's a dressage barn
i guess is there any significance when
you would register for a a show or a
competition to registering associated
with a certain barn
i mean yes there's always there's always
that significance
um depending on you know judges might
you know
favor have a preference towards a
certain coach or think that
you know they're more of a prestigious
barn so you're getting a better
education they might be paying closer
attention to what you're doing but
there's i believe there's definitely a
significance to who you're training with
when you would compete in a competition
or a horse show were those competitions
or horse shows held at michael
barrasson's farm
no where would
would it be fair to say they would be
held out of their locations yes
how would you get there with your horses
they would be trailered in a trailer and
who did that
um either michael himself or justin
harden
is that something
that costs money
uh yes if you're getting it done
privately
and was that included in the price that
you were paying to michael barrasson
during the time you were there yes
now between living
at michael barisson's farm at times in
the same
house
as well as being coached and trained by
him did you make any observations of his
personality
yes can you tell the jury what your
observations were
my observations were that
there was times where he was hilariously
funny and charming and nice
and then there were days where
you would just see him and he just
looked
angry
and you just you just knew that day you
did not want to approach him you might
even see him like you know screaming at
a staff member
and even though maybe it hadn't happened
to you yourself yet
you just
knew
don't go near him just keep your
distance
you said that he uh
was was hilarious or funny something to
that nature what was the nature of his
sense of humor
he would just tell funny jokes and
um you know
i i can't think of a specific example at
the time
um sometimes the jokes he would tell
were not funny
and
offensive to be honest
um but at least i mean i guess he
thought they were funny
now at any point during the course of
time that you were dealing with him
professionally
uh did your relationship change
yes and would you say that it got better
or worse
worse what was the worst thing michael
barrasson ever did to you
tried to violently murder me on august
7 2019.
now before i ask you some questions
about that um
let me ask you do you own any guns
i do uh how many guns do you want i own
one gun
and did you ever have that
on either of michael barrasson's farms
never
where did you keep that handgun
my home in north carolina and what type
of a gun was that is a walters nine
millimeter ppx
do you remember approximately when you
bought that
somewhere between 2015
2016 i want to say
and can you describe for the jury
generally the process that you had to go
to uh go through for applying and
purchasing that gun yes
um
so once you choose
the gun that you want to buy
you then have to get a permit
and so they do a background check
and then you're required to go to the
sheriff's office like they send you
like
i guess the message of what you need to
do
and you follow those instructions and in
one of those instructions is come to the
sheriff's office
and they'll ask you questions
and
if you need to provide anything you
provide it and give you a permit and
then you have your permit to actually go
and pick up the gun that you've decided
upon
and are you describing that process as
the same process you went through yes
that was north carolina right yes
have you ever used any drugs in the past
yes
what drugs
i've used pills
at one point i made a terrible decision
to use heroin
um
that was mostly it oh
pot probably
and
what uh when you say pills what got you
started using drugs um
an injury and i don't exactly remember
what it was i was doing a lot of sports
at the time
um somewhere in my like early 20s
and
i guess i went to a doctor and
he prescribed me some pain medicine i
had no idea really what it was i started
taking it and i became addicted to those
painkillers and on and off addiction
issues with painkillers
since then although i had clean time
after that on and off too
well
are you sober now yes
did you ever use any illegal drugs at
the time that you were living on
michael's barristones farm in the summer
of 2018. no
how about the summer of 2019 no
do you take any medication to help you
maintain your sobriety i do can you tell
the jury what that is
one major drug that i take is called
suboxone
and
i take that drug to pretty much ensure
that
i maintain sobriety
does it help you
yes it helps me tremendously
do you see a psychiatrist or an
addiction specialist i do
no i think i asked you this question
before but i asked you specifically
about facebook
and i think you said that you're very
active on facebook
[Music]
let me take you back more specifically
to the summer of 2019
okay uh would you ever be involved then
or before uh playing any sorts of games
online or through mobile devices
yeah
um
a few not so many but there were
definitely a few
what were some of your favorite games to
play in that
way chess with friends definitely number
one for me probably
um
then i small bout with farmville for a
little while but i would save all of the
games chess with friends by number one
what is your uh favorite thing about
playing chess
i think it heightens intelligence and
makes you
think of things in different ways
and mostly it was just a challenge for
my mind i like to enjoy playing it and
enjoyed having
um
you know like anonymous people to play
with or friends
and it was just
something to do to
heighten your intelligence and have fun
at the same time
now i had asked you questions uh a
couple of minutes ago about the day in
august when the defendant shot him in
the chest
i think you indicated that you remember
that that was august 7 2019
where were you when the defendant shot
you
i was on the porch
on
a um
like a love seat
that was on the porch that i would often
lay on to read and
or you know sometimes watch a movie on
my tablet
um and i just lay on the couch outside
nice weather
so i was on the porch
right there on my left seat
and were you
so
this happened at the farmhouse yes and
were you still on the porch when he shot
you
no
i'll ask you some questions about that
more specifically in a few minutes okay
um
you said a few minutes ago about how
obviously the relationship that you had
with michael barissone had gotten worse
yes me ask you some questions about what
was going on between you and michael
barisson okay were you having any issues
during the summer of 2019 related to
your coaching or who was coaching you
yes can you explain that to the jury
yes
so
there was a time where
justin hardin had sort of become
the
my main trainer
in a way
and
i was not happy with that
because i was paying a lot of money
for the training specifically
of michael barcelona
and
you know not to sound indelicate but
i didn't feel like i was paying all this
money to be at the you know justin
hardin
academy of dressage i was specifically
there for a specific trainer
there are other issues as well
he had a drinking problem which i had
brought to michael's attention
and
i guess that that's pretty much what had
happened and i guess in general is it
fair to say with respect to who was
coaching you or how you were being
coached were you vocal about that to
michael barrisson yes
how did it make you feel
uh that
justin for example was your primary
trainer and it was no longer michael
um
just like
tossed to the side and then i was just
there to pay money and
board my horses
and nothing more sometimes it seemed
like it mattered and he was interested
in
you know our progression other times it
was just
justin take this
kind of thing
during the summer of 2019 when you were
at the farm in new jersey
did things change in terms of the times
that you arrived allowed to be at the
barn or the times you were allowed to be
around the horses
you just repeat that one more time
so during that summer of 2019
at some point did things change about
when you could be at the barn or when
you could be around the horses yes can
you tell the jury about that
um
yes so we had agreed in
2019
um that
we would do night check on our horses
which is checking to make sure
that they're basically tucked in for the
night they have what they need
and we agreed
that we would be up there
do it everything we needed to do and
you know trying to be out of there but
as close to 9 15 as possible and just be
done
so that would honestly go to bed but
everything we wanted to have them settle
for the night by that time anyway so we
kind of came up with that agreement
and that's how it was settled
during the summer of 2019 did you bring
another horse
or a new horse to the barn
yes michael um
had
pretty much insisted that
this horse come
to his farm
and i took her out of the rehab that she
was in
to bring her there so
sometime in i believe it was early june
possibly
late may
um
that horse did come to his farm at that
time
did that horse specifically have any
health issues
yes that's that's why she was in rehab
she has
a condition called chronic cellulitis
which is where
a limb or
several limbs but usually just one
just blows up full of edema and liquid
and it could range from
mild to potentially fatal
did you have any responsibility as the
owner of the horse for taking care of
that
yes i always have responsibility if it's
my horse and if i didn't ask you this
earlier uh is it fair to say that rob
would help you at times with certain
things related to care for the horses
almost almost always
so specifically in terms of of this
horse that had the condition
what did you have to do in terms of
providing care to the horse on a daily
basis oh lots of things um
starting with evaluating
how she was looking how she was eating
taking her temperature
but most of all
applying
these things that we call standing wraps
which are a combination
of like a white
wrap made of cotton
which you then
cover
with another wrap made of sometimes like
polyester
that you wrap that over to keep the
swelling down so basically a compression
sock with just a few extra details in
between
and how frequently would you have to do
that or change it
pretty much every 12 hours like 12 hours
on 12 hours off or you risk
other secondary injuries happening like
a
tendon so does that mean you were
typically doing it about twice a day
yes
when would you typically
at what times of day would you typically
try to to do that 12-hour change i'll
try to get the wraps on
around 9 15 and
take them off
sometime around the same time in the
morning
i figured 9 15 is a good time so
i don't have to get up extremely early
to remove them
or in the reverse
put them on and then take them off at
those reverse times
during the summer of 2019 you sort of
alluded to this before but did you have
any
issues going on between you and mary
haskins gray
yeah
and without getting necessarily into
specifics can you tell us generally
about that
she was
just always condescending and she was
doing strange things like stealing my
gloves
out of my locker at least that's what i
thought
um
there was an incident where
she
put
i had a bridle that i was using for my
ride
and
before i went to go
put the bridle on that horse
i turned around and she took it off my
locker kind of like that the handle of
my locker and walked away with it saying
this isn't hers she can't use this and
just walked away with it and there are
other minor minor little things that
happened as well
i guess uh
do you do things the same way that mary
haskins gray does them
no does she do things the same way you
do them no
do you do things the same way that
michael barisson does them
no
did you ever see him do things exactly
the same way you do them
no
as i remember
did you ever feel like
are you talking about in taking care of
horses or
generally it's rather a broad question
it's intended to be judged i think it
was uh
i can i can clarify that though
miss counteract would you say that you
were
treated differently if you acted
differently from mary haskins
with respect to your behavior
yes i was treated differently would you
say that you were treated differently if
you acted differently than mary haskins
with respect to
your demeanor at the barn
a hundred percent
would you say you were treated
differently if you acted differently
with respect to
riding a horse
yes
with respect to the way you
dressed
yes the way you
use social media
yes
could i keep going
yes i mean you could
how did that make you feel
when you were treated that way in
response to the way you were acting
bad honestly just
i thought it was i was being treated
unfairly
and
i didn't really understand why but
that's the way that i felt about it
now at some point
would you say that
this started to happen or you started to
feel this way on
more of a day-to-day or a more regular
basis
yes
it progressed
um sometimes
more quickly and sometimes less quickly
but there is definitely a steady
progression
do you remember approximately when that
was in the summer of 2019
trying to think
i would say
sometime in the area of
mid
july
mid july maybe early to mid july
is probably when it started
or when i noticed that things were
really starting
that's when you started to notice it
yeah
did you ever make any direct threats of
violence against michael barrisson never
did you ever make any threats of
violence against michael barissone using
facebook
never
did you ever make any threats of
violence against mary haskins on
facebook never
did you ever write things on facebook
for example that you knew
would be or could be unflattering to
them
now you mentioned in
july of uh 2019 or the summer of 2019
i'm sorry that you were living on the
top floor of the farmhouse yes and
uh
michael barrasson and mary haskins were
living on the main floor
correct
at any point would
anyone else be there at times
living in the same
living area with michael barrasson and
mary haskins yes
mary haskins had two children
whom i believe were
12 at the time
and they would pretty much occupy the
basement
did you ever have any observations
during the time that you knew the
defendant or knew mary haskins and her
children to see
the defendant interacting with the
children i did
now it's and i think you said this but
just so we're clear did the children
live there full time
no
what was your impression or recollection
about
times they may be there or may not be
there
they would just come
sporadically and stay
sometimes for a week sometimes two weeks
i believe there was a time they may have
stayed for like a month
but mostly it was just like a week or
two visit
every now and then
now at some point did
michael barrasson and mary haskins move
out of that
house during the summer of 2019.
yes do you remember approximately when
that was
i believe it was
either the
last day july or the very first day of
august
but i'm pretty sure it's the last day of
july if i had to guess do you know where
they went
um
i believe they went to the barn
you mentioned before i think that
well let me just ask the question
do you recall where the working students
were living that summer
they were living at the barn
do you recall where justin hardin was
living that summer
also at the barn
and using that last day of july first
day of august as sort of a reference
point do you remember if anyone else
who wasn't in in that category
uh coming to live or coming to stay at
the farm on an overnight basis
around that time
i'm sorry i wanted to make sure i had
the question right could you just repeat
that one more time sure so we use that
as a reference point when they moved out
of the house and moved up to the
clubhouse
did anyone else come to stay at the farm
uh
around that same time period at the
actual farm or the or the farmhouse
just at the property
um
there'd be visitors like um one of the
working students parents came to visit
ruth cox
came
during that very same time as well
make sure nobody else came and i can
recall
i believe that's it
um what is safe sport
safe sport is
a
basically an oversight
for olympic sports
to
make sure that
there are no abuses
of either
you know competitors and trainers
that there's severe protections over
minors
they're basically there to make sure
that
there are no
violations of
like egregious rules
and to keep the sport and the community
safe as a whole
did you ever make a complaint to safe
sport i did did you ever make a
complaint against mary haskins or
michael barrasson to say sport i did
do you remember
approximately
was that the same complaint or separate
complaints it was in the same complaint
and do you remember approximately when
you made that complaint
i think it was around august 2nd
i
believe can you explain to the jury the
process you went through to make that
complaint
yeah it was
um
sort of an involved process
um first i called
the i guess the safe sport like hotline
um i was
everything was kind of just
going
there's a lot of tension on the farm
and i wasn't really sure
if i should make the complaint
so i first called the safe sport hotline
to discuss with a person there
just the whole situation
and they kind of talk you through your
feelings and
help you decide whether
making a report is the right thing to do
or not
and after i believe it was a long
conversation
with a member of their hotline
i decided that yes
the right thing to do here is to make a
complaint
so i then
call the number where you make a
complaint
which can also be done
by filling out a form and sending it in
which
i didn't have the equipment to do that
so i just made it by phone
i called somebody and i made the
complaint by phone
and that's how that transpired
did they ask you certain follow-up
questions during that call
yes
what was the general basis of the
complaint or the reason that you called
to make a complaint there were a few
um
mainly it was severe bullying
um like
torturous bullying
and
there was also some stuff in there about
body shaming
um
and that's pretty much it it was mostly
just bullying
and scare tactics
and things like that and just
a show of
you know power over
someone smaller basically
did the person you talked to ask you any
questions about whether there were
children involved
yes they asked repeatedly
if there were children
simply just living on the property
before even getting into involved
they were asking over and over again
this is going on are there children on
the property so to that i would answer
yes
they did ask questions though yes did
you make any complaint against michael
barissone
for sexual abuse no
did you ever make any complaints to
child protection or whatever acronym or
name you may know them to be yeah
now during the week or so leading up to
you being shot by the defendant
do you recall if the police had ever
come to the property of 411
west westmill road i'll say
can you repeat that prior to my voice
trailed off uh during the week leading
up to you being shot by the defendant do
you recall if the police were ever at
the property yes
do you remember approximately how many
times
i don't remember the exact number i want
to say a total of maybe
five times
it could be off by one or two give or
take
did you call the police at all during
that week of august uh what i'll call
august 1st to august 7th yes
how many times
twice leading up to
that day yes
leading up to that day i called them
once i believe
and did you also call the police on the
day you
got shot yes
did the police to your knowledge come to
the property the day that you called
them
i do not believe they did no
so is it fair to say that any time the
police showed up at the property that
week it was not because you called
that'll be exactly correct did they come
to speak with you without getting into
what they said did they come to speak
with you a number of times during that
week yes
now at some point in that week of
approximately august 1st to august 7th
did you become aware that there was a
lawyer involved representing michael
barrasso
at some point during that week yes i did
become aware of this and how did you
remember becoming aware of that
actually i don't remember exactly i
received a letter
but i don't remember how i ended up
getting that letter
what was the
what was the general what was your
takeaway from that letter
it was a little bit confusing but the
takeaway letter was
this person does not want you on the
farm
so look for someplace else to go kind of
thing
do you remember when you received that
letter
i believe
not the exact date but i want to say
possibly august 5th
when you got that letter uh did you have
a meeting with a lawyer i did
and what was the purpose for you going
to meet with a lawyer
um we had some things that were
unresolved
and
we do not agree
with some of the things that were in the
letter and we thought it was best to
just let lawyers handle it
the right
way
when when you
did you have a sense at some point
before you got the letter that things
were not going well and that you
probably needed to leave yes
why didn't you just leave
well a
moving five horses which
at that time i had a fifth horse
um
i'm sorry it was whispering can you
repeat the question
sure uh i asked why you didn't just oh
why oh that's right so yes
um
first thing is that it is extremely
difficult to move
five horses
and just find another barn where they
have five stalls available
and
most importantly
training
like you worked very hard to purchase
these horses um make them competition
horses
and
it's hard moving one horse you know on
short notice
but moving five
is
almost unthinkable to have to do on any
short amount of notice
do you uh do you have your own trailer
i do not
were you scheduled for
or or had you already registered for any
competitions or shows that month of
august yeah the week
after the shooting
i was scheduled to go show at one of the
biggest showgrounds that we had in our
region
sovereigns
it's called hits
and so there was a show the following
week i was said to leave
on that following wednesday that'll give
us the 14th
and
that was our plan was to go to that show
so i could continue earning the scores i
needed for my goals
ma'am saugerties
new york oh yes i'm sorry yes saugerties
let me direct your attention to
wednesday august 7th do you remember
generally what you were doing that
morning
on august 7th so yes i'm sorry
uh yes i was laying on my porch couch
i was lying i was on the porch
i was laying on my porch loveseat
um
you know on my tablet
um
[Music]
i either reading something or
watching something i'm sure maybe in my
phone
judge if i could have permission to show
uh the witness s330 345 in evidence
yes 345 will be showed for the witness
and the jurors
[Music]
miss cataract i just wanted to use this
picture uh just to orient
some of your testimony for the jury
what is s345
a picture of
the back porch
and uh
what is the big red item that's in the
middle of the picture
it's an umbrella
did you put that umbrella there
i think
robert did i don't think i'd be able to
put that there myself
now that doorway
uh on the side of the house there is
there a doorway under the overhang yes
what did that doorway open into
it opened into
two things
that that's the way i would describe it
open to a laundry room
um which is
sort of like a common
area
um people who do the laundry in that
room
but also
was the entrance way specifically
to the apartment that robert and i were
staying in the summer of 2019 as well a
big stairway leading up to that
apartment
and so is it fair to say that that would
be the doorway that you would typically
use to come and go from your apartment
yes that was the only doorway
understanding that there wasn't anyone
else living in the house
at this time in august of 2019
how would the people when the working
students live downstairs
what door would they use to come and go
um you can't see it in this picture
but there was a
stairway leading
downstairs
and then there was a door
and that's how they would enter
it's sort of to
the left
of this
uh i don't know what to call this thing
with little diamonds in it like the
lattice yes
um to the left of that
there would be a stairway to see
like
it's like sort of blocked behind there
like a shadow
that's where the stairs i think i
believe led down to there was generally
a separate entrance or a different
entrance that they would use exactly
exactly now you said that you were
sitting on the porch on august 7th 2019
correct can we see that in this picture
you cannot see row sitting why not
because there's a giant bush
and that's the bush that's right in the
middle of the screen yes
so behind that bush there's a porch
yes do you remember approximately how
many steps up
that porch would be from ground level
not many
maybe maybe two
three at the most i would think
so you were sitting you said on a like a
love seat on that porch
do you see the love seat
in this picture somewhere
probably moved from where you would have
left it or been laying out uh oh yeah
i think i can't miss that you can see
the back of it
behind
the chair
that is behind the little yellow uh i
guess evidence
uh triangle thing
behind that chair
is the back
of the loveseat it's sort of like it's
like made of
and i don't know
based on the nature of this photo judge
that the uh
pointer will work
but if i could just have miss kanrak uh
step down and point out the love seat
for the jury
should i
yeah do you have the uh laser pointer
we do judge i'm not sure that it will
work on the this photo
it is
if i may approach yeah go ahead
you can try that
to see if you can point you press that
button
right
there
judge i believe the jurors in the
gallery
i could see that but if you can can you
see that members of the jury
it's kind of hard to hold the button
thank you thank you
so that's the love seat you were talking
about
is that where it was when you were
sitting on it no where was it
it was
on the actual porch
and was the umbrella
positioned there for a reason
yeah what's that um it was positioned
there for pretty much
a couple reasons mainly rain
which is why you see it's kind of like
attached to the awning of the porch
we set it up so that
rain could not come in
so
and also for sunlight if there was like
a glare in some way kind of just covered
all bases rain sun weather
it helped
now on august 7th
you said you remember at some point you
were
laying or sitting on that love seat on
the the porch by the entrance into the
house
before that did you have any
interactions
with michael barrisson that day
that day no
did you have any interactions with
anyone from the barn that day nope
and i'll specifically direct your
attention to about two o'clock that
afternoon
uh was anyone else present at the
farmhouse when you were there
not that i knew of
no one else was at the house
oh the house i'm sorry
the farm no i'm probably being confusing
saying farmhouse i'll start calling it
house
was anyone else present at the house yes
who is that robert
robert do you know where he was
he was
upstairs somewhere probably bedroom
watching tv or on the phone or something
now when you were sitting on that love
seat yeah
did anything catch your attention from
the area of the driveway
yes can you tell the jury what that was
yes
um
i was laying on the
left seat on the porch
and i began to hear
pebbles kind of like being thrown around
and it was coming from the barn
um
sort of headed towards what i thought
would be the road
and
that's what caught my attention first
was just the sound of pebbles and the
sound of what sounded like a
heavier
truck or car coming down the driveway
did you see a trucker car
i did eventually what did you see i saw
a
a big silver dually
um
come over the crest
and
turn into the driveway
where
the porch area is
and
[Music]
park and and based on
living at the farm and and working or
training at the farm who commonly drove
that
silver door
michael did you see who was driving
not at first
when you saw the truck come over the
crest and then pull into the driveway
where you were sitting what did you do
the first thing i did
was ran upstairs
to go and let rob know
that michael was here
all of a sudden at that point could you
see
what rob was doing
yes what was he doing he was on the bed
and he was on the phone
and do you know or did you come to learn
who he was talking to i did who is that
um our one of our attorneys and david
and how do you know that's who rob was
talking to he told me
did rob do anything with the phone
uh
meaning
he stayed on it
and
came downstairs with me
so you went downstairs uh when you got
downstairs did you come to that same
i'm sorry
did you go to that
same doorway that you just identified
in the photo s 345 yes
did you see anyone outside at that point
yes who did you see
michael barson did you see where he was
yes i did
can you tell the jury where you saw him
yes he was
on this side
of that bush
um
with a partial
area of his body
kind of like hidden with the bush
and the rest of his body
was
pretty much completely visible
so like what part of his body could you
see
um
like from here up
um his arm
and that's that's pretty much it and
just because uh
we're recording all this but not
necessarily video recording it when you
say from here up where are you gesturing
oh i'm sorry um like
way stop maybe
could you see his waistband
um
i don't remember if i was able to see it
at that moment or not
do you recall where rob was at that time
yes rob was
at that time
on the porch
next to me
was he still on the phone or did he do
something with the phone
he was still on the phone when we saw
michael
and then at some point did he do
something with the phone yes what did he
do with the phone he hands it to me
did you talk on the phone at all
i did i think but i don't know what i
said at that moment i think i just said
michael's here
i don't know why
something along those lines and do you
recall whether or not the attorney was
still on the line
yes he was
oh
did without getting into specifics did
you hear whether or not rob and michael
barissone talked at all yes
did you hear michael barrasson say
anything
yes what did you hear him say
i heard him say
um mostly speaking to rob at that point
um
you know i don't want a war how do i fix
this how how can i make this all better
something
along those lines almost exact words
along those lines how can i make this
better
i don't want a war
i just want to fix everything and make
everything good again
what
or how would you describe his demeanor
when he said that
calm
just
yeah i would just like calm
was he yelling
no
did you do anything after hearing him
say that
i
after hearing him say that
i
went down
to go find out
how he wanted to do that i was willing
to listen to this
whereas
robert
when he said this i guess to robert
robert just said listen you know there's
lawyers involved
we can make things better that's fine
just you know have our lawyers talk
and
rob went back up onto the porch
i then
was thinking you know all this stuff had
been happening
for the past couple of days
you know michael have been calling the
police on us for reasons that we didn't
even know why
and
not this that it was out of character
um for him to act one way one day and
then you know be nice the next day
but
i kind of wanted to know so i walked
over to him and said
you know
how do you plan to make this better how
do you you know you have
a bill or something i was
saying something about
the bill that he had to settle with rob
but i didn't get that far
because why not
the minute i started talking pretty much
or
yeah within the minute i started talking
he pulled out a gun
and shot me once
twice
directly in the chest
at that point do you remember if you
were still holding the phone with the
attorney i believe i was
did you have anything else in your hands
no
how tall are you
five four
do you know how tall richard garrison is
i believe he's 6'4
did you see the gun
i did
do you remember
how he was holding the gun
was it close to his body or pointed out
and held away from his body
it was kind of like
he pulled it out pointed it
boom
boom
just like that
can you tell the jury
what you remember seeing
or hearing
when he fired the gun
wait i'm sorry
can you repeat that one i wasn't
sure
can you remember or can you tell the
jury what you remember seeing
or hearing
when michael barissone fired the gun
i remember
when he fired it
what i was seeing her hearing
i remember seeing my chest
um
why'd you look at your chest
it was almost unreal to me
that
i just got shot
so i looked at my chest quickly
to see are the really holes there like
this this can't be real
um i also then saw
michael raise his arm up
and shoot at robert who was on
the porch still just directly raised his
arm
shot at robert
and then robert disappeared
at that point
i saw michael run around me
and go running up the stairs of the
porch
and
i don't know it's just some of it's a
blur but
do you remember after
seeing that you had been shot did you
feel it
i did i felt it but
i almost remember thinking i i did not
start bleeding right away so i looked at
my chest and thought oh
okay maybe there's
blanks or something
but then i started bleeding
[Music]
do you remember what you were wearing uh
at least in terms of a top or tops yeah
i was actually wearing a red shirt
um
with like gray sleeves
since i usually always wear hoodies
i'm pretty sure i was wearing one that
day as well
i think like a either a yellow or a gray
one
and by hoodie you mean uh a sweatshirt
yeah like sweatshirt that zipped up i
think i had it unzipped
with a hood
after michael barrisson shot you twice
in the chest you said that you saw him
turn the gun and point it at robert
yes well he shot at me he shot shot me
and then
yeah he he raised the gun up and
immediately
took a shot at rob
and
when i looked at the porch i no longer
saw rob so i fully thought that
he was shot in the head and killed at
that moment
do you remember what you did
right after that
right after he shot me right after he
shot you and you saw him take a shot at
rob
i
um i feel like
spun around in a circle or two thinking
like
is this real is this real
and
then i looked on the porch
and i saw rob
on top of michael
trying to hope like restrain him
because i guess
i didn't really see how that happened
but
since michael went up the stairs
to do it only i could imagine was to
finish
or make sure that he did actually yeah
don't don't assume anything just tell us
what you saw what you heard okay thank
you
can you repeat i'm sorry go ahead ask
ask a question mr shellhorn were you
still holding the phone at that point
yes do you remember
specifically do you remember making a
9-1-1 call
i didn't at the time no i told the
lawyer that i was on the phone with what
had happened
now at some point uh
do you remember being on the phone
with 9-1-1 whether you remember actually
dialing or not
vaguely
do you remember what you said to the
9-1-1 operator
i said something to the effect of
i just been shot two times michael
barcelone shot me two times
or shot me two times in the chest
something along both those lines
when you were making that call or when
you were on that call
do you remember approximately the area
where you were
on the near on or near the porch
and so if we're looking at s 345
you're talking about that area
near where the
red umbrella is yes like like almost
underneath
an area underneath that
area
judge if i could have permission to play
s113
certainly
um
oh
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
okay
come on come on
come here
[Music]
is
okay
i need to get the person's description
okay black white hispanic or asian his
name is
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
sir where the building are you
oh
are you
sir where in the building are you ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
all right
was the voice that we heard
at the beginning yours
yes
who is the second voice the man's voice
that we heard
roberts
when you were making that or on that
phone call with the 9-1-1 operator
at some point
did you give the phone to rob or did he
take it from
took it from me i'm pretty sure
do you remember what was going on at
that point
yes
what did you see
i saw
as i said before
i saw michael run up the stairs
towards
where i had seen rob disappear
and
when
i started going over there
after i had seen the two of them which i
saw robert
on top of michael
the first thing that i saw
was that michael had the gun directly
underneath him
and rob was on top of him
with
i believe he had michael's left arm
like just held behind his back
and he was over him
um
and the only thing i kept seeing no
other than that
was that there was that gun right there
just right there and if rob had let go
or something
i couldn't keep hold of any more
it would be so easy
for michael just
get that gun
and
shut fire more shots
did you do anything when you saw this
happening i did
um and it's sort of like
walk crawl
motion
i
approached the porch area
to where they were i don't i don't
exactly remember whether they were like
on the porch or on the pavement just
below the
you know two or so stairs
and
the first thing that i actually did
was i tried to dial 9-1-1 from my phone
except
with the phones back in 2019
um
my arms had actually started
bleeding well they weren't bleeding my
chest was bleeding so badly that my arms
and hands actually had so much blood on
them
that i couldn't open my phone
and
i was just thinking i can't download i
can't tell i'm not one i heard rob
screaming
michael stop moving
stop moving like repeatedly saying this
and
on my trip up to where they were near to
where they were
i just remember that gun being there and
how close it was to michael and how easy
it would be for him to get it so
i at some point during all this
decided to take my phone
and i just
i felt myself losing energy
but
in spite of that i took my phone and i
started hitting michael on the side of
the head with it
thinking that maybe this will help if he
might if robert is losing his grip on
michael
and
he gets that gun
we're going to die
so i just took my phone and started
hitting him on the set like the sort of
the side that he was facing
and my phone ended up breaking in the
process
of that
when when the defendant shot you
do you remember approximately how far
away you were from him
three three four feet not even
the dog that we heard barking
was that the same dog that you looked at
a picture of earlier yes
do you remember
when the police uh or first responders
arrived at the scene
it seemed like
instant in in oh instantaneously almost
i was actually shocked
he called 9-1-1 it was almost
like
it felt like seconds i'm sure it wasn't
but it felt like
instantaneously there was an officer
that had arrived on the scene it wasn't
like 30 minutes had passed in other
words do you remember what happened when
the officer got there
i do sort of remember
um
i remember that the officer had
separated
michael and
robert
um i believe
he like
made sure the gun
i don't remember if he if he like
tried to see if there was a bolt in
there
and
uh separated them but he definitely did
some kind of
motion to that effect and then got the
gun and
its pieces out of the way
uh separated robert and michael
and then
basically said to michael you know he
was still trying to move said you know
if you keep moving i'm going to fucking
kill you excuse my friends just
quoting what the officer said
um
do you remember when other officers and
emergency medical arrived again like
oh it seemed to me like almost
instantaneously
officer one was there
and then it was like
officers were there
in general
do you remember leaving
the property
after i remember i'm trying to think
i remember
getting into a something
a angelic i guess a um
like an emt
van or whatever
um i don't remember i actually left the
property or not
when you say uh getting into
did you get in on your own
power or were you put there
i must have been put there because i
don't actually remember going in i just
know that was in there
because i
at some point opened my eyes and
realized i was in
a
i wasn't even really sure where i was at
i'm assuming it was an emt van i had
like a one flash of waking up and seeing
that and thinking
i guess i'm not dead what's the next
thing you remember
the next thing i remember
is
the next thing i remember
is waking up and
i was in icu
and i had no clue how i got there
or
how long i'd been there
um i just opened my eyes and almost
immediately just felt
pain
through my body
i didn't immediately see anyone
and then i saw a nurse and i realized
i think i'm in the hospital
but i didn't know how long i've been
there
were you connected to any
medical machines or anything like that
i can't imagine
that there's a less amount of medical
machines that one could be connected to
when i woke up i had
um
said i want to see muppets um like mitts
on my hands
and that's like one of the first things
i noticed was why am i wearing mitts
i'm sure there's a lot more for me to
worry about but that's what i thought
and i noticed that
both my arms
had like iv uh
drains and things going through them
and then i noticed
i could not talk
or
breathe or
really
i i just couldn't make a noise
at the time i wasn't sure i just was
i
i don't even know how to describe it
did you have anything connected to your
mouth i did i had a ventilator in my
mouth but at the time i didn't realize
like what that was
i just realized like
i felt like i was like
just something was stuffed down my
throat
i had things all over my body
and
i couldn't cry out for help or
you know say
somebody what am i doing here
it was just like
surreal
surreal
how did you feel
when you
regained consciousness and
realized all these things
i felt a combination of things
i felt a combination of
afraid
for some reason still
and
angry
and
a little bit um
like wondering if if it was at all real
like
i die am i like in limbo right now or am
i really in the hospital
no idea what's going on
i knew i remember
there i did remember there was a
shooting but i
i just didn't recognize any surroundings
and i didn't immediately see any human
being
so
i didn't know what was going on and if i
was about to die in five seconds
or whether
there had been you know surgery i just
didn't know what was going on
how did you come later to find out that
you're at morristown hospital i did
how long were you at morristown hospital
before you were discharged approximately
i want to say approximately three weeks
are you still recovering
yeah how so
well i still have
from my sailing here
over
and even
a little bit to the right of that
um
just
build up of scar tissue
inside and outside my body
um
another and i don't mean to put you on
the spot and put you on a show but if
you could just stand up because you were
gesturing and just because we have
jurors back here so you could just show
them
the areas where you're gesturing to on
your body that you have
you don't have to show no you don't have
to show us man just just point out where
that is please
right here
there are three giant holes
where tubes were placed in my body like
that about that size
in the diameter um
there's a scar a giant scar going all
the way up here
which goes around my belt there's a
scalpel
mark around my belly button
and then continues up this way
goes around
this whole
left like breast area
around to all the way in my back
shoulder blade
and
that is where the exit wounds are so
they're still those that are visible
as well as
two entry wounds which after now it's
been two and a half years or a bit later
but pretty much this whole side of my
body
is
mrs frankenstein fish
mowed me and i'm just going to show you
one picture that we marked as s 388
and i only uh show you this picture
because you described where you got shot
in the chest so the jury can understand
where those gunshot wounds are
is it all right if i display that judge
yes
it's in evidence
approximately how long after the
shooting was this take this photo taken
uh maybe
i was singing a month or two maybe
and are the two gunshot wounds from when
michael barrasson shot you did we see
those on this picture
i'm sorry
what was the question i'm so sorry
do you see the uh
gunshot wounds in this picture yes
can you just tell the jury specifically
where they are
they are
to the right
of the necklace one
two
and you said you had two
other gunshot wounds on your back from
where the bullet went through bullets
went through okay
have you at some point since the
defendant shot you been able to
start riding horses again
thankfully yes
are you riding at the same level that
you were at the time that the defendant
shot you no
i will train
you know some of the movements but
it's
the point pretty much where
the trainers that i have now
um have come up with like different
contraptions actually to
help keep my left shoulder blade from
falling forward
and
i mean
when you're riding you want to be
upright and be able to use your body
correctly to
give the horse the correct cues and aids
and
show that you're the one giving the
instructions
that can't happen when you have
almost one whole side of your body that
wants to collapse
every time you try to stand up try to
sit up straight basically
and i'm going to show you what's been
marked in evidence as s402a
is that a photo that you posted on your
facebook page
yes is that photo uh
well who is in that photo
on the left is michael barassone
uh
i am on the horse and standing in front
of me is
my mother
and did you post that photo in april of
2019
uh
i believe so it was like a photo
challenge on facebook
to show
does it indicate that it was uploaded
april 7 2019.
i'm not sure where i'm looking
oh there's a yes it does say that it was
i'm not sure if it was uploaded at that
time or if it was
um
used at that time for
what we just saw was like a facebook
challenge to post uh
i guess a
time that was special to you with a
horse or whatever it said and what was
special about
this time with this horse
with these people
this is the time when
this specific horse
had just sometimes recently
come over from um
europe i forgot which area of europe
this specific horse had come
he had come
we'd gone to a show
and i was working towards
um earning my bronze medal
and at that point i just gotten
one more of the scores i needed to
complete that medal
and so
we're kind of all smiling celebrating
the fact that i
not only achieved the score but went
well and
over the score needed to achieve it
judge can i have a moment
yes
i don't think i have any further
questions at this time thank you all
right very good given the hour direct
examination is done sounds like a good
time to break for lunch ladies and
gentlemen
uh we'll take our lunch and recess now
until
come back about
1 25 or so and we'll get started shortly
there after we cross examination thank
you
[Music]
just leave it there man that's fine
make sure
[Music]
so
like katie when the jurors have left you
can excuse
media and observers in the courtroom all
right thank you
yes
you can have a seat miss cataract you
remain under oath
cross-examination mr blancas
good afternoon miss cataract
are you currently suing michael barrison
yes
you're claiming millions of dollars in
damages correct
i don't know the amount
of money that we're claiming but
certainly for damages
basically want to take everything
of value away from michael
in that lawsuit correct
i just want him to
cover medical expenses and
answer for the crime he committed in a
civil
court of law
and also get money correct
if that ends up being a result
of the suit
i guess that's the result that's not the
goal
and all of that
and correct me if i'm wrong
is based on the fact that he shot you on
august 7th correct
that he tried to murder me yes
is it in fact
that you
your boyfriend and your father
we're planning on suing michael
barrisson
prior to that
not that i recall
but i don't remember what would be suing
him before prior to that
other than recall talking to your dad
about uh
suing them for approximately two hundred
thousand dollars
i do not but
i i don't recall that actually
is it your sworn testimony that as you
sit here today you have no recollection
prior to the shooting of talking to
either your boyfriend
or your father
about suing michael barrasso is my sworn
testimony that i at this time do not
recall
that especially amounts
now
did you have a plan
to destroy michael barrasso
at some point yes
and
isn't it the fact that
you made a specific threat
saying that you intended to destroy
everything mary haskins
loved and held dear
at some point yes
you made that statement for
both mr barristone and miss haskins to
hear correct correct and and would you
agree with me that uh
you set out on a mission to try to do
that correct
at a certain point after being bullied
correct
there's been testimony here that
no one ever really asked you to leave
were you at
you can't refer to other testimony to
this witness strike that
just ask a question of this witness
please
isn't it a fact that you were asked to
leave
in july
no i was not asked to leave in july
how about april 27
2019
where you basically told
time to leave
can we clarify who was purportedly
telling her that
did you have a conversation with michael
barriston
had a conversation
with michael barrison mary haskins
my father
and my boyfriend
in a meeting that i called to which mary
haskins
began that meeting with
y'all need to leave
so yes that would be correct i guess in
the way that you asked it
and
when you were told you all need to leave
did you start taking
steps
to pack up and find another place to
stay
yeah
now
at that point in time
uh would you agree with me that uh
things have turned sour between
you
your boyfriend
and everyone at
dressage
stables i would not agree at that point
in time
no
since michael
in that meeting
told his girlfriend many times
to
i'm just quoting here so please don't
mind the cursing
to please shut the fuck up and not speak
again
this is a business arrangement and she
should not be making any kind of
assertions
such as you need to leave or whatever
so that was the end of that conversation
now
when
did the problems
start to occur
i would say they started to occur
somewhere in the area of
maybe julyish
i want to say
maybe a little earlier but
july would be probably more accurate to
when
july
approximately a month before the
shooting correct
approximately
now
have you ever lied to either the
washington township police department
or the morris county prosecutor's office
about this case
not that i recall
have all your statements
that you made to them
been truthful
yes
have you hidden anything from them
no
you gave a statement december 5th 2019
to the prosecutor's office do you recall
that
no i'm sorry can you actually repeat the
question i missed the date sure
uh december 5th 2019
you gave a statement to the moore's
county prosecutor's office with regards
to this case correct
december 5th
2019. okay
probably yes i don't remember the dates
but three almost four months after the
shooting correct yeah yes then probably
yes
that is the first time you gave them an
official statement correct
i don't recall i believe i spoke to them
before that but i don't remember
that
yes
recently in preparing for trial
you were played your video of this
transcript correct and i'm showing you
200g
okay
was that was that a yes you would play
the video
oh that was a question i'm so sorry i
think it was was that a question where
she yes will you play the video in
preparation for trial
was there anything in that
video statement
that was inaccurate
um
[Music]
i can't remember exactly
um i feel like
when i was telling them the amounts of
shots fired
um
i feel like i said
definitely three times maybe maybe the
times a bullet shot
i couldn't really remember that
didn't you say there were five shots
i don't know what amounts of times i
said i know i said three shots were
fired i may have said six shots i don't
remember
okay so
a few months after the incident
when you talk to the prosecutor in
official capacity
your recollection is
three four
five shots
as good as you can remember correct
yes
i i guess so yeah
i just been shot a few months before so
i was just giving a statement as to what
i recalled
and your recollection is a little bit
different today correct yes
now
before you gave that statement
you had uh
talked to your boyfriend numerous times
about the incident correct
correct
and you talked to your father about the
incident correct yes correct
was robert goodwin in the room when you
gave that statement to the prosecutor
i don't think so
now
would you agree with me that in your
original statement
you said
that you had a problem remembering the
incident
did you say that
in my i'm sorry my original statement to
the prosecutor's office the ones that
that's right in front of you
i'm just i'm sorry i'm just confused i'm
not sure that
this december 5th was the first time i
gave a statement
and there was some
judge can i just clarify for the record
the interview occurred on september 5th
2019
i think not december transcript uh says
december 5th 2019.
so there's a typographical error there
but certainly the recording itself
indicates it was september 5th what's
the date council september 5th 2019.
i just i think that maybe
it may be
all right i i apologize this is what was
given to me
september 5th 2019. yes was the first
time you talked to the prosecutor's
office yes
do you recall telling the prosecutor at
that time
that it's a bit shady in my mind or
words to that effect
honestly i was on a ton of pain
medication
i had just come out of the icu
i honestly don't know what i may or may
not have said even if i've watched the
video
i honestly don't remember what i said in
that interview can you please turn to
page four
sure
line
12
and ask you if that
refreshes your recollection as to
whether or not
you indicated a month or so after the
incident
that you were a bit shady
as far as your recollection of the event
i'm so sorry i can't find where you're
talking line 12 says four lines says
that's okay from detective rogers
[Music]
so this is actually page three
page
this is page four line 12.
um
detective roger starts with an 11.
speak up as much as you can
right away
okay so some of them okay 9 12. wait 10
11 12.
the number on the left hand yes i see
just the page numbers are
in different areas okay sorry continue
does that refresh your recollection as a
way whether you told them with respect
to the incident it was a bit shady in
your mind
uh probably yes
[Music]
do you recall telling them
words to the effect that
after the shooting you went somewhere
no
i don't recall telling them that i went
somewhere
can you look at page four
line 14
did you tell them words to the effect
there were parts of the story
there were parts of the story
like
where'd
you go
like i don't even know like i
disappeared
yes that would be accurate
you told the prosecutor's office on that
day
and supposedly after you were shot you
disappeared somewhere
correct like mentally like i i
mentally disappeared that would be
accurate yes
your testimony is that
by the word disappeared you meant
mentally
i mean i
i could read it but yes i could read it
how loud if you'd like whatever you
would want me to do read it to yourself
he's asking i guess what what you
what did you mean when you said
back when you gave that statement what
what did you mean when you said those
words that's what he's essentially
i think when i said those words i meant
what i thought i was saying was
i think i like you know went somewhere
or something like in my mind like i spun
around in a circle
or
you know
i wasn't like
fully aware of the i was aware of the
fact that i just been shot
but
also
still thinking like maybe this isn't
real
so like i wasn't in my mind in the
proper place
so
as you sit here today yes
at any point in time
either
before or after the shooting
did you
run off
to the side or around the house
i never ran around the house
i like i said a moment ago
if anything i may have ran around in one
small circle
just kind of assessing myself but no
further nothing else but you never
disappear
physically that's my specific
question ugh
[Music]
now
you indicated
at some point in time
with your relationship with michael
barrasso
you decided or set out to try to destroy
him correct
at some point i'm sure i mentioned that
or said that
you uh
you wanted to ruin his business correct
i think finally
yeah that was in my mind
and uh you wanted to uh
ruin
and destroy his girlfriend mary haskins
correct
i guess yeah after what they were doing
to us that thought had crossed my mind
also yes okay now when you say
what they were doing to you
the problem
incorrectly from wrong on direct
examination
where things started to deteriorate is
when uh you weren't being trained by
michael barriston correct
i wouldn't say that anything started to
deteriorate it was part of it but not
the entirety what were some of the other
parts
just
things here and there a lot small lives
being told
um
bullying
but when you say bullying what what
exactly do you mean
who bullied you on one occasion michael
jumped out at me in the dark
started screaming at me and spitting in
my face
and at that moment
i didn't know whether he was going to
try to hurt me or
i don't know do something to me what was
that
when is that when was that that was
sometime around the time that they were
no longer living in the house
and in the barn so he was like waiting
for me to come up there
did you ever tell anybody or call the
police i posted on facebook i'm being
bullied by a 6-3 man to the point that
i'm afraid and some other thing
that's i wrote about it and with regards
to facebook
looking for
with regards to your facebook account uh
you were posting things daily correct
correct
and and a lot of those were about
michael barrasso and mary haskins
correct
correct
and and
would you
agree that some of those things could be
considered
threatening i could agree to that
like um
your
use of the terms with regards to a uh a
chess game
to recall saying things like the king
will be killed
the queen will be sacrificed
i don't know honestly i was talking
about a chess game and
it might have been an analogy but
but it the analogy was towards michael
barrison and mary haskins correct most
certainly
and you also used metaphors at times
uh correct correct
and you did that
you
know to what try to protect yourself by
not using names
i'm sorry can you repeat the question i
you use metaphors correct
yes
and
and for instance in in one instance
did you use the
metaphor where you talk about michael
barrison as the king
and mary haskins is the queen
i honestly don't know who i was
referring to as being who
but i'm certain that was about the both
of them
oh
on july 14th
prior to this meeting where
your base mary haskins tells you to get
out
to recall uh
posting a
extremely long post
where you're talking about a king and a
queen
and
your relationship with them i'm sorry
you started out with on july
14th prior to
you think i'm sorry you repeat the
question i'm so sorry
i'm going to show you what i'm referring
to here
i'm going to show you 28-14
[Music]
okay i'm not sure where the date is of
this
this is from your facebook account
and there's a date up top that says
7 14 2019
lauren cataract
reacts to a post from july
oh yes okay i see
and the highlighted is what i wrote
i'm gonna ask you some questions about
this
you're familiar with this post
correct well i am now
i wrote it so i'm familiar with it on my
page
and and uh
would you admit that it's it's pretty
scary
if
you're talking about the person
that you're talking about here
did i think that calls for sexually
speculation okay
just ask her about the post
when you talk about the adulterous king
lured by a peasant of no merit no
credibility
in ousting the rightful queen
in the most humiliating way
in front of a large audience who is the
king you're referring to
probably michael
probably yeah i'm assuming i'm not
referring to his ex-wife vera right
so therefore would be my goal
and who is the new queen you're
referring to
mary haskins
and did you call her
the most dumb-witted commenter village
idiot
would suit her perfectly known in all
the land
she is not royal blood
she has no regal talent or talent
whatsoever
did you say those things about mary
haskins yes
others refer to it as the queen of lies
and deceit i myself
have not found it necessary to refer to
her at all
did you say at some point
referring to her
that she herself could never
possess the talents that the wife did
she was blinded and paranoid with
jealousy and the thought of the king
realizing her true nature she began
executing all the younger and fairer
mating of the kingdom
referring to mary haskins correct yes
now you were aware that mary haskins
michael barissone and pretty much
everybody at the stables was were
following your facebook account correct
i had no idea what the anybody was doing
at the stables or starting my facebook
account
other than maybe michael on an occasion
one time said he saw a post but other
than that when did he say that
sometime while i was training with him
it might have been shown to him by a
girlfriend or maybe he saw it in his own
he actually complimented it
not this post a post at some point
and he was just like i agree with
something that he wrote and
other than that i had no idea what he
does with his facebook account or
what he reads who shows and what
[Music]
did you
also say in this post
sadly the once fearful and formidable
king
michael
had been transformed into nothing more
than a slight memory
of his glory days
with less and less tales to tell
of conquering than ever before
did you say that
yes
did you say a man made
small
and nearly worthless without his queen
by his side
of the yes that wasn't true to your
finish
and did you also say the more frail the
king became the easier it also became
for the imposer
wannabe queen to whisper lies into the
king's ears did you say that
yes and you were referring to michael
and mary haskins correct correct
judge just so the record is clear it's
his imposter
i apologize all right
the record shall reflect
[Music]
lies she hoped would rid
every maiden young and old
of true royal blood
and with varieties of talent from the
kingdom forever
were you
suggesting that mary hatkins was trying
to destroy
the careers of all the young people at
the stables yes
did you then say at some point
failure to abide by this agree his
agreements
with other royal
houses
invite open war
and inevitable destruction
yeah
you were basically declaring war on him
correct
um
i wouldn't go that far
well
there were certain agreements that you
claimed that he didn't honor with you
correct okay
and and this post was referring to those
agreements correct
i mean yes it's also a reply
to a comment
that
mentions things like royalty and other
things so
there's parts that i honestly don't know
what i'm talking about but it was
written by me
so
[Music]
it's there
yes i wrote it
did you say unfortunately
what's iqc mean
i don't
we're not know
where
did you say unfortunately iqc composer
queen
commoner
used the king's diminished state
to quietly convince him to ignore all
treaties
i have no idea
i have no clue
oh iqc
there actually is a thing for that um
i'm sorry could you do that again just
so i know exactly
first do you know what i c means yeah i
see it i
i put it in parentheses
what does it mean brackets
it means
i just saw it i will get to it um
impostor queen commoner
did you then say the queen
on the glass throne isn't a queen
yes
she is hardly more than pond scum
attached to the boot after trudging
through a puddle did you say that about
mary haskins
yes he did
you realize that mary haskins was his
girlfriend correct
okay
did you think if he saw that post that
that would cause an issue
with regards to you staying and training
at his facility
i'm sorry i just wanted to get sure this
make sure i have the question right
you're asking i thought
if he saw this
whether it would cause an issue
with him
continuing to train you
and allow you to stay
at his facility i don't know it doesn't
but i thought really hard about
it or the consequences i just kind of
wrote it
you just threw it out there
basically
did you then say her open attacks on me
will not result
in the execution
as it did for
the matings fairer
than she without any counsel to fairly
protect them did you make a statement
like that
i'm guessing it's there yes i'm
saying i wrote these posts so yes
and
did you end it by saying
something to the effect
but all the king's horses
and all the king's men
couldn't put humpty
together again
and
that the castle
would come
crumbling down
did you did you say that
yes and the castle you were referring to
was his business correct
i honestly don't know what i meant i
don't know
what you meant when you wrote this is
that your testimony that's my testimony
i have no idea what parts or pieces of
each micro thing i was referring to i
was just in social media i wrote stuff
that's what i did
okay and did you make a statement at the
very end words to the effect i sure hope
my wrath
is never called upon
did you say that yes
judge could i ask for completeness
pursuant to the rules of evidence that
the next line be read judge if if he's
asking that i would ask that if the
entire thing be published to the jury
you have redirect
you can do it on redirect that's fine mr
blink has brought it up and if you want
to bring in other portions of it you can
do so that's why we have redirect
now
you were also posting things about your
mental instability on facebook correct
not that i recall
not seriously anyway
when you say seriously enough
did you make specific mention
of you having serious mental problems
um
i do recall one specific post which one
was that it was a post sometime i don't
know when i wrote it but it was a post
in reply to my cousin
um which the gist of the post was fear
and i discuss
hiding in a bunker
or needing to hide in a bunker but prior
to stating that
i say something along the lines of
i like
have mental um sorry
um
i'm trying to think about the words
multiple yeah emotional personalities i
don't know what they're going to do if
they're threatened
but just actually
like
a little bit of
um
assumed knowledge on the part of the
person i was sending the message to
i thought she like
knew the situation
and that would understand that i was
referring to michael's behavior
of acting one way one day
one way the next day
and i just
was writing it and assumed that she had
more knowledge of like that whole thing
than she did so to make sure
i then went on to say
what basically we're so frightened that
we're thinking of building a bunker to
but hide ourselves and maybe even can it
fit horses if you have the post you
could bring it out but
i plan on it but okay
just i was just saying sure at the time
um so you do
admit
that at some point during this
relationship you posted something saying
you had multiple personalities
and you're not responsible
for your actions
yes
did you ever post anything that you're
a narcissistic and suffering delusions
of grandeur hashtag bipolar narcissist
possibly
those are the types of things that
you would say
there's lots of types of things i would
say
so i mean social media
did you make reference to
weapons
frequently
another recall
but
i'm sure i mentioned that i own a gun
[Music]
i'm sure i mentioned that
new jersey gun laws are very strict in
other states maybe they have film laws
that are right straight also as they
should be
um especially since i ended up getting
shot by one of those very guns
so there's that but
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off do
you recall posting photographs of
on facebook of you
shooting your boyfriend's motorcycle
because you were angry that he
was riding with that john yeah this is
subject to a rule yes where are you
going with that mr molinas
we phrase your question
hold on and please keep your voice up
nice and loud okay so all the jurors in
the back
okay have to hear you all right
you testified on direct that you only
owned
one gun correct
okay
did you post
that you have two nine millimeter
walters
yes i did actually post that
did you lie about how many guns that you
possessed no i was not lying about it
i was talking to a friend of mine who
he and i frequently discuss
politics and what have you
and in this discussion
um
what i was referring to
was
the gun that i had currently
i also at the same gun store
put money down on another gun which i
never went to go get and instead of
explaining
like what would have been a 17-page
thing i just said
i have two guns but
that guy would certainly know that would
be the case because i would have needed
another permit to go get it so in a
simple
sentence or two i just said i have two
guns both walters
which
is technically true seeing as though i
did put money down
to purchase that gun i just never went
to go get it
so
it didn't feel like explaining that in
facebook
it's your understanding that
if you put money down on something and
don't
pay for it
completely and obtain it that it's
yours i guess that's the concept of
putting something on layaway or
things like that that's my
interpretation
when did you put that on layaway
um
sometime around the same time
that i went to go
do the whole process of purchasing and
actually obtaining
the first weapon
did you post that you have a nine
millimeter
under your pillow
i don't remember possible
now with with regards to
your statements concerning
own owning two
guns
both walters nine millimeter pistol
one takes 18 in the mag and one in the
chamber the other is small enough to fit
in my purse
i haven't cleaned it
in a year
yeah i was actually referring to the one
i had not the one i didn't have yet but
yes i wrote that
which which one is the one that holds 18
in the magazine
um
the one that i actually have possession
of i'm pretty sure it's 17
now that i
checked it like recently
in in that same post yeah i think i
don't know which is on august 4th three
days before the shooting
did you say words to the effect
that if someone were to punch me in the
face i'd let them twice
after that
their second hit advantage would be over
until they begged me
to let them up
how probably but something sounds
unfamiliar about that could you maybe
read the few lines preceding that
or like maybe however many lines there
are just a few lines that right before
that so i know
i haven't cleaned it in a year
hashtag fail unfortunately or luckily we
both live in north carolina new jersey's
crazy gun logs you could be arrested to
due time for just having one bullet
mine are mostly hollow points
which just one
is the potential of 10-year sentence
even if it's
loose and sitting on the floor
that couldn't be the post because that
post
where after it says luckily
it says i'm not a violent person right
so you didn't read that just then you
was always confused you read
that okay
i'll read the whole thing yeah please do
thank you potential 10-year minimum
sentence even if it's loose and sitting
on the floor also luckily i'm not a
violent person i hate confrontations
which seem
seem
they could turn violent that said
if someone were to punch me in the face
i'd let them twice after that their
second hit advantage would be over until
they begged me to let them up
self-defense yes that's the correct pose
i did write that
and so
you were telling
whoever had access to your facebook
post
that you owned two different guns
correct
correct
and that i wasn't violent but yes
now
were you posting
things
with regards to your uh
your experience using guns
probably
for instance that your ex-husband owned
the gunshot and you shot
pretty much every gun there is
yeah
it's very sad
did you brag about being a better shot
than your boyfriend
probably
and did you say at one point with
regards to uh
your gun that you only need three
bullets
my aim is nearly perfect
i don't know could you read that that's
um
i have no idea can we be heard at
sidebar yes i think we should
all right ladies and gentlemen the
objection was sustained and before we go
any further i do have to give a limiting
instruction on some of the testimony you
heard
you heard me mention earlier i think
after openings that there are some uses
for evidence that are allowed by the
jury and some uses that are not allowed
i'm going to go through all this again
at the end of the case when i give my
main charge and i'll give some
references at that time to specific
evidence and how you can use it
now this evidence about
miss cataract owning
a firearm was allowed in by the court
for
a limited purpose
and that purpose is
as it may have affected
mr barrissone's state of mind
at the time of the shooting that's why
it's allowed in
if
it's shown that mr barrissone had
knowledge of these postings you may or
may not consider that as evidence of his
state of mind it's entirely up to the
jurors but it's not introduced to
um somehow attacked the character of
miss cataract it's not introduced as
character evidence
it's only introduced for a limited
purpose of how those postings may have
impacted the state of mind of mr
barrisson that's the only reason the
court has
allowed the introduction of this
evidence regarding miss cataract's
possession or ownership of a firearm all
right i'll address it more at the end of
the case
all right please proceed mr belinkus
miss counteract
did you refer yourself
as john wick in any post
who is john wick
uh
someone like
keanu reeves
it's a violent person
um
my pers
i think it's a matter of perception you
could say that i guess
did you have a husband
like this
were you posting uh
in numerous posts
statements with regards to
going to war
you say things like if war cannot be
avoided
then the victorious war warrior must
hashtag
win first
hashtag then go to world war
or worse to that effect
yes i believe i was
quoting some too
but i'm sure it's probably posted if
it's hashtagged and posted
with regards to your chess comments
did you make a statement
every time i up my chess game i always
become reminded
that it is those
who obsess about protecting their queen
regardless of the outcome
who miss the hiding
and
you always something like that
probably and you were talking about
michael barystone protecting his
girlfriend correct
probably
and in that same post did you say can i
ask what what date you're looking at or
page or something
this is
july 12th
2019
and at the end of that post did you say
the king has been captured
and
and killed
and the whole entire castle comes
crumbling down
did you say that
probably
and
that sometimes the queen must be
sacrificed
did you say that
yes
would you admit with regards to this
post
you were talking about
capturing and killing
michael barrison
he's with the use of metaphors of course
correct
i was definitely not talking about
killing anyone
that'd be false
how about sacrificing the queen
was that mary haskins on a board of
chess
where a piece is knocked down
or moved over
sure
[Music]
on that same day
did you post something the beast
hasn't yet met the napping beast inside
me objection
same objection judge
i'll sustain the objection
now
during this time when you're making
these posts
you're telling
numerous people on facebook
that you're being bullied correct yes
and
you even tell them that you believe your
life
is being threatened
that's correct
now with regards to your posts
july 21st 2019
after posting all these things many of
which we've just gone over
did you say something to the effect that
you're
never be bluffing
never be bluffing not unless you're
prepared to carry it out did you say
words to that effect i'm sorry what date
and what this this is
july 21st
a couple weeks before the shooting
did you make a statement basically
saying you're not bluffing or words to
that effect maybe i don't know what the
context was but what pages up
top right
oh uh 10 24
and on
july 21st
did you dare
again talk about
what you're saying
not being a bluff
and that no one with a brain in their
head bluffs empty
bed and literally
you do
and just did
bye bye
exclamation point did you say that
yes i always usually end off with bye
bye or bye bye
so that makes sense
when you say you'd normally end with bye
bye
to anybody yes
[Music]
now on
july 23rd a couple days later
did you use the term
weapons hot
yes
july 25th
did you post a post
and and this is when things are really
starting to get crazy
at the facility correct yes i'm sorry i
can you just go back to the post from a
minute ago
about i'm moving on i have a lot okay
because i mean
strange of that i wanted on july 25th
did you post
i will be
it's about time to possibly go to war
anyone who repeatedly kicks a resting
beast
will eventually wake her up
probably yes
on the 27th
did you say words to the effect this is
me look out
because here i come
i guess i believe i was quoting
uh
the president circus movie
with hugh jackman
it's literally a song
did you say okay
14.
no
[Music]
you
were you okay
i'm just looking at the page that you
said look out because here i come but
what peter said
that's not him no i don't think that's
in there he's looking at something
completely different
why don't you take that away so we don't
have that mistake again and after
looking you're not referring to it
now
at some point
you start illegally recording private
conversations correct objection
closer conclusion mr velancos
did you record
private conversations where you were not
a party
yes
now
at some point in time
in corrections i'm wrong
i believe
[Music]
on august 3rd
you tell the washington township police
department
that you've recorded secret
conversations correct yeah i told the
police that i was recording things yes
but
you also lied to the police about that
recording did you not
i don't know what capacity in what
capacity you're talking about so
no
i would say no did you tell the police
that an attorney gave you permission to
record
um i don't recall but i was speaking
with attorneys
and what attorneys were you speaking to
um
i guess i could tell you their names but
i'm stars privilege um ed david
uh my father who's a retired attorney
um
there's someone else oh
i don't think they're involved this time
i don't remember there is definitely
somebody else i believe but certainly
those two people
one is a current attorney
one is a retired attorney
and we discussed
the location
what the expectation of privacy might be
the reason for which and the legality
and the legality of course
it wasn't like a decided thing before a
judge but we discussed those
possibilities so we could avoid doing
something legal
all right so
and again correct me if i'm wrong is it
your testimony that your father
told you
you could legally take the private
conversation that you were not a party
to
objection
the basis for your objection it's
hearsay it's not offered for the truth
of the matter judge
what's an offer for that has to do with
why she did this
i'll allow it
not not but not for the truth correct
just her state of mind it's your sworn
testimony that your father told you a
lawyer
that you can
put a recorder
someplace
and record private conversations when
you're not there
no is that it
is my sworn testimony that
either
my father or
the lawyer that we had obtained
expressed that it was their belief
that the location in which the device
was placed
um
and the reason for which it was placed
there
seeing as though it was considered my
property um was not breaking any laws
we specifically sought out this
instruction or council
to be sure that we were not going to be
breaking any laws
by doing this okay we weren't trying to
shoot and you want to kill them we just
wanted to do things the legal way
i'm asking you specifically
was it your father she just said let's
ask an answer she said twice now either
the father or the lawyer okay well are
you aware of the fact that i have a tape
recording
of the meeting
between you robert goodwin
your father
and your attorney edward david where
you're discussing
tape recording
i am not aware of what you have
but we have many conversations so if you
have a conversation
then
you have a conversation yeah i have a
conversation no mr blankist you're not
offering evidence
maddy hurt josh
all right let's take our afternoon break
members of the jury
take 20 minutes
does it matter to mr barriston when he
heard it whether it was illegal or not
illegal no well it's it learned no
that's just disparaging you're attacking
the vic the the the alleged victim here
i'm not because i have text messages
where she uses these recordings to plan
on suing him she gets the recordings to
her that's not a but that's not an issue
i i understand mr belenkus i understand
why you're raising the issue
your focus now on was it illegal or not
illegal
right and and the whole purpose of this
is as it impacted mr barrissone yes well
to a certain extent
what's the other extent what she's doing
it's a lie she made to the police and
the prosecutor she says i put the
recorder in my helmet in my private
locker that's what she just said
she never even said that yes she did she
has not said that yet well that's what
she's going to say she said depends on
where she put it i have text messages
where she talks to her father and
goodwin about putting recorders in the
residence the barn the clubhouse
by the dumpster by the rock you know
that's the lie that she made to the
police regarding this case
what's what's the lie she made the lie
she told the police i have recordings
that i made uh
that were in my my helmet in the locker
you know there's no expectation of
privacy she made tons of other
recordings in other places for instance
in his office judge in the clubhouse and
then takes those conversations takes the
exact words and starts taunting him with
them
so i think it is it affects her
credibility it's a lie i'm trying to
attack what she said to the prosecutor
and the police
i don't know how it's established that
that's a lie judge yeah so even if
so it can't be mr davis they talk about
it and then they even say and two
lawyers agree that even if a judge tells
them to destroy it they're going to
disregard that order
i know you're going down this road and
bringing all this strangers this is the
evidence i have so when the prosecutor
says oh i don't know where these were
made the text messages indicate that
they were made
i know but but you
you you asked the the lead into all this
was
did she lie to the washington township
police department
right right
so why don't you focus on that
you know you got hung up on this illegal
thing but what just hear me out okay you
got hung up on the illegal thing that
determination's not being made here and
and we're going down the road and quite
frankly whatever point you're trying to
make is going to get lost in the morass
of whether it's illegal or not the the
issue is did she make conversation did
she make recordings and then use them
and post them and did that affect mr
barrisson and that that's what i said
initially regardless of whether it's
illegal or not illegal
they're recordings of barristone
apparently that were posted
my belief judges
and i'm putting this on the record
whatever you rule obviously i abide by
i'm putting this on the record because
basically it's clear from the discovery
given by the prosecutor that they know
she's committed a crime
illegally recording barristone in
private conversation they've not charged
her i've asked them have you discussed
charging you can you can ask for those
questions but but not her opinion on
whether it's illegal or not that's not
her decision to make
okay but so it's like for instance if if
if i shoot somebody and the prosecutor
doesn't charge me
everyone knows you can take judicial
notice judge that illegally take
recording someone in a private setting
without their consent is illegal it's
it's i know but if she says an attorney
told me it was okay to do it which is
part of her testimony then she wouldn't
be prosecuted she'd she'd rely on legal
advice whether it was right or wrong
and if she relied on it then she's not
going to be prosecuted and do you real
do we really want to go down that road
in this case no judge but i have to take
with edward david or he questions
illegal he didn't tell her it's legal
that's the one person she says she's not
sure if the other person is her father
and i was cut off with with regards to
trying to no because you kept asking the
same thing and she kept
repeating the same answer twice you
didn't like the answer so you were going
to ask it again she said twice it was
either
this attorney david or my father who's a
retired attorney then you asked it again
she said the same thing
okay and i have i'm just saying for the
record judge i have to take where it's
clear that ed davis
the first day she ever met him and they
even talked about this he had no idea
she was taping them
she tells the attorney that i placed
them in my locker and and there
there's no expectation of privacy and
the boyfriend is heard crystal clear on
the tape laughing ha ha ha well maybe
not all of that i know but this is this
is so far from the issues here mr
blanket i'm excluding it under 403. it's
just going to lead to confusion
and a waste of time
on on a exceedingly tangential issue
here you can ask her
about what she told
washington
pd about the recording whether she ever
put recording devices elsewhere
that's fine
but but going off on this is it legal is
it illegal and he spoke to an attorney
what advice did she get that's
that's just way too far afield and it's
it's just
it's going to lead to confusion on the
part of the jury
and
a waste of the courts time quite frankly
i'm going to exclude it on that ground
but you can certainly ask her
and pursue the point excuse me about
whether or not
what she told
to washington whether it was accurate
whether there were other recording
devices
and and things of that nature
and that's relied upon by um
i think the experts as part of the
insanity defense here
okay so it's relevant in that regard but
just stay away from whether it's illegal
or not illegal if you if you want to ask
her does she have any fear or
prosecution or did was it ever discussed
with the prosecutor about her not being
prosecuted
i suppose that may show some interest or
bias
so that's fine
all right
yes go ahead
[Music]
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
please
[Music]
just give me one moment judge
okay
oh you may have a seat man thank you
josh
i will resume cross-examination by mr
belinkas thank you go ahead sir
mrs counteract uh i'd like to talk to
you about these tape recorders
um
on august 3rd
michael barrasson calls 9-1-1 and the
police arrive correct
i am assuming yes and after
they talk to him they come and talk to
you correct
probably
they didn't always but
i'm assuming at some point they talk to
you correct yes
and on that day
you told
the washington township police
department that you were secretly
recording
private conversations correct correct
um did they ask you any questions
as to how you were doing this
um
i don't recall i just remember
something about just make sure it's
something that you own because make sure
it's not attached to a phone or in a
living residence because that could be
considered wiretapping
and i said no not there it's on some
place that
it would be considered my property
and it's not attached to a phone or a
living quarter
or anything like that so they said okay
it's your testimony that the washington
township police department
is
discussing
the legality of what
you need to do
to take a recording no it's my testimony
that they were
offering insight into what to be careful
about if that's an action you're going
to take
they're saying just make sure that
whatever you do you don't do
these things because they're definitely
illegal
definitely you were told they were
definitely illegal or they're definitely
judge i'm going to object we just talked
about this at
the break this this is what was told to
her judging
by the police if you frame it if you
frame the question that way about what
the police said it's fine but not not
anything further than that right so the
police told you
you can't record in someone's private
areas correct in someone's like private
home
or like you can't bump a phone
so
they follow those instructions did they
ask you specific questions on
on how and where you were doing your
recordings
no but i was sort of like telling them
because i wanted to and i wanted them to
know
i don't remember how far into it i went
but i i wanted to be sure like i said a
moment ago
that i wanted to make sure everything we
were doing was legal
and we were going about it the right way
okay and and at any point in time since
this incident as the morris county
prosecutor
or any representative ever
question you about where you put these
recordings
and what the circumstances were behind
them
i believe so who
who what who
did you talk about these recordings
about
in the prosecutor's office
i know it was in their office i'm sure
just and i
done
um
just
i'm not sure what the title is
christopher shaw learned
um
did you tell him whoever else is in
their office did you tell chris shut up
i didn't go further did you tell
christopher
where you planted all the recordings
that you made regarding this case i
don't believe i
specifically discussed where they were
we didn't really want to like get into
that we were discussing more the fact
that i was almost murdered
and where was some recording
on in you know where it was placed okay
well
is it an effect
that you did record
conversations in a private residence
no that is not a fact
did you record conversations in the
clubhouse no
did you record conversations
in
either the residence where michael
barrasson lived or
the staple area where he
lived a week or so before the shooting
so no he never lived in the stable area
ever
um he lived
in the clubhouse
which there was no recordings there
but
yeah your second the second portion of
your
um i guess questioning
is
not accurate so if maybe you could ask
it again
michael barrasson never lived in the
stables oh he lived in the club area
correct which is separate from the
stables pretty clear
sworn testimony that you've never
recorded any conversation in the club
area
that's correct unless it was
recorded
on our person
and it's one of us speaking
and we were in the club area which we
were not during that time
so i would have to say yes it's correct
that there was no conversations
in the club area recorded
i've been provided over 70 recordings
okay
where were those recordings made my
locker
every single one
um no not every single one
somewhere in our own house
um somewhere in
i don't know i don't know where else
they were there i know where they
weren't
i can tell you that i know they were not
i know that they were in my locker when
we were recording
like an open space where anybody could
be at any time well again when you say
an open space
is it your testimony that you secreted a
recording
in an area where you or robert goodwin
were not present
well we were present because we had
horses stable there
so when you say present i mean present
during the actual
conversation yes if you're asking if
there's conversations that happened
while we were not in the actual
stable area yes there were conversations
that happened during that time correct
okay and
you've indicated that you didn't do that
in the club area correct yes
how about michael barrisson's private
office
did you or robert goodwood ever put a
reporter
in michael barrissone's private office
and record private conversations no his
office is in the clubhouse
in the club area
correct sorry say it again
his office is a separate room from the
club area correct his uh his office is
literally inside the club area there's a
door
but it's in the club area and again
since that was also their living area
no we did not go ever in the living area
and record anything it was in my locker
or in the area we were living
at the house so again to answer your
question it would be no
i'm sorry
about me being confusing
okay so
again in a roundabout way
you answered my question i'm just going
to ask you specifically
irrespective of how
the room is positioned
did you ever
secretly record
private conversations in michael
barrasson's office no
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes
who got this reporter
um my boyfriend ended up buying it rob
goodwin correct
and uh when did he get that reporter it
was ordered on the morning of august
31st at around 807 a.m
from amazon
august 31st i'm sorry july 31st
july 31st and arrive next day
i believe arrive the next day correct
and so tonight is it your recollection
that over 70 recordings were made from
that point on to the time of machine
there are two devices i believe i could
be wrong
um i don't know how many recordings
there are but
there could be a hundred still the fact
remains
this is where they were
and this is where they were not they
were in my locker
they were in the house that we were
living in
we were talking to ourselves we have
adam report but where they are not was
in anybody else's living quarters
including the club room or any other
living residence in the farm
whatsoever
unless that living residence belonged to
a horse which didn't it was in my locker
end up
now
you just mentioned that there were two
devices
correct at least i believe so i wasn't
in charge of them
who was in charge of that my boyfriend
was in charge of them but we both knew
where they were okay and you were the
one instructing him where to put the
device correct we would discuss it
together i was it was no like i'm
instructing him or he's instructing me
we had a specific reason
for them
for my wanting them to be in my locker a
very specific reason
i guess he had a reason to
but nevertheless like i said that's
that's really
locker which i was paying for did you
turn over both of those recordings from
the prosecutor's office we turned over
everything and i was
again
i was shot and dying the police
collected what they collected i was in a
hospital for three weeks in a coma for
four days
i don't know what happened during those
time during that time but certainly
i had no
knowledge of what the police were doing
or
any other office was doing but i do know
that we turned over everything that we
had
because it was taken upon search and
seizure
of the crime scene
um
that unfortunately your client committed
okay now
with regards to these tape recordings
when you recorded something
did you bring it back to your house and
listen to what
was on the tape sometimes
how did you listen
to those recordings at your house
what device
a computer i think i think you just put
it in the computer and it plays
and you could also delete things off
that with the recorder correct
i have no idea i'm pretty sure you could
do it anyway anybody could delete
something but
our goal wasn't to delete things it was
to get the information we're trying to
get which was we thought vital to our
life and ended up exactly coming to
fruition
so a few days just a few days later
in almost the exact way i would say it
was
um heard on those audios
so
i can have a moment
did you ever put a recording on the
porch
i'm not sure which porch you're from the
porch of the front of the staples
no unfortunately i said
and i just i don't mean to
like
sound like i'm being rude or repeating
myself like that don't worry i
the only place that the reporters were
ever placed
in that barn area at all
was in my paid for locker that's it
otherwise it was
on our person or
in the apartment that we're living
and
that's it
now whose telephone number is 973
seven one three seven
seven zero three my father
and that's one of the persons that you
claim
gave you a legal opinion with regards to
recording correct
one of the people i like and again said
i don't really remember
which
said what or who said who but i
certainly spoke to my father a few times
and
do you remember your dad saying on
august 2nd 2000 injection
has to do directly with this issue
judgment doesn't matter it's still the
rules of evidence isn't that a hearsay
statement judge i believe it's
permissible to impeach you
there's a discussion with her father
regarding admissibility
i mean isn't this what we discussed at
the break no judge this is a specific
statement which contradicts what she
said
all right
hold on the objections over won't so go
ahead and ask the question in this one
area
your father's number is 973-713-7703
correct
did you have a discussion with him
on that day
with regards to the
on what day yeah that hasn't been made
clear one day
august 2nd 2019
at 9 24 pm
with regards to
him questioning the admissibility
of you
making these recordings
yeah he's questioning the admissibility
rather than legality
of it then i'm guessing probably spoke
of
whether
after these recordings have been
recorded whether or not they might be
admissible in a court of law since you
just mentioned the word admissibility
i'm really pointing out that
i don't think we're talking about
like is this legal is it not legal we
may have been i think the
the real crux of what we're discussing
but just like you said a minute ago the
admissibility of it meaning
will this be admissible at a later date
if that's what you're asking which it
seems to be that is
wrong
you were
giving your father copies of these
recordings correct
um i don't remember i don't really know
how i would share them
i'm really not that tech savvy
is in the fact that you're aware that
your boyfriend robert goodwin had given
your father a number of these taxes and
you were aware of the texas recordings
and you were aware of that
on august 2nd
like i said it was ordered the morning
of july 31st
they arrived probably the next day if
we're lucky so by august 2nd
i can't imagine there would have been
very many recordings by that time
so i don't know what he could have sent
in that one
like time period
for like a small
period of time
to my father but i can't say he hasn't
so maybe he did i honestly don't know it
wasn't me
if it happened and when you used the
term admissibility yes that had to do
with the lawsuit that you your father
and robert goodwin were talking about
filing against michael barriston correct
um probably not just that probably
some other things too
now
you also make videos
put video cameras places correct
in our living space yes we are planning
to go away
the following week with michael in fact
to a show
which i had signed up for
um it's on the usdf website you can
check it
i had entries for a show the following
wednesday
where
michael was to take me to a show
the one we were discussing earlier
um in saugerties new york called hits
hits on the hudson
and we wanted to have surveillance
in the house for when we went away
since there was tension on the farm
you know people going back and forth
with their moods and tempers
so all i knew is i had a show
i wanted to have surveillance in our
house that you're renting
and we had
cameras blink cameras i believe
um in the house
or when we were not home
that was the purpose of them so yes to
that question
and when you say
or said in certain posts that you have
eyes and ears everywhere yes that can't
be detected
where were the eyes
for those the guys
in our house which if no one's living
there
why would they be detected unless
someone's coming in it shouldn't be
who's rosanna williams
a good friend of mine
also um
she is one of the
best
international for sales
people
maybe on the in the world
and i purchased three of my
international
competition horses from her
um
and
we just
we're very good friends and also a
business friend as well
now
when did you get these uh
cameras that you're talking about
i didn't get them
um my boyfriend did i don't remember
what date but
somewhere around the same time
as audios same time that would be after
somewhere
somewhere around the same time as audios
and you're sure that
no i'm not sure that that's why i said
i'm not sure i didn't get them okay
where did he get them at i think you
order them online like a person would do
i'm guessing
well do you remember having a
conversation on april 20th
with miss williams
saying april 20th i'm sorry
april 20th
2019.
judge i think i think if the intention
is to refresh her recollection which
she's saying she doesn't remember she
could certainly be shown something to
see if that refreshes her memory
[Music]
yes
all right i'm showing you
a text message
and the number of prosecutors 9311
april
20th 2019
thank you
i'm going to ask you to look at
item number 9311.
this is april 2019 did you say no
and ask
for you to read that
um just read it to yourself
just to refresh your memory a little
yellow opposite thing no
just
i just point it right out to a judge to
save something yes go ahead point it out
what you wanted to read
okay
this is rosanna correct yes this is you
talking correct
okay i read it
you bought cameras
no i said that i did to my friend
months before
so but there was no cameras purchased
so you lied to your friend about
purchasing cameras because you thought
justice was a threat justin was a threat
yeah
i feel like she was worried about me
to make her feel better i said don't
worry
your cameras will be fine we later did
get cameras but it wasn't two months
after
okay
[Music]
but you'll agree that there was a text
message between you and miss williams
where you indicated on
april 20th 2019
that you bought cameras last night
to plant in the mr
you just refreshed a recollection
and panetta you know i know but and that
now now i'm impeaching her with her
recollection because it says here
they play well no don't don't don't read
it that's the whole issue
so you use that to impeach your
credibility right and refresh your
recollection
and you're saying her last statement
that she said is not accurate about
what's in there yes judge
absolutely
did you tell her that you planted
cameras in the apartment
and the barn
is this the thing you just showed
it doesn't say the apartment it says our
apartment yes exactly i was leaving out
key words every time that he reads these
text messages
all right mr mr shellhorn
[Music]
if you have an issue
it's not to be said in front of the
jurors all right i i understand
but just say you want to be heard at
sidebar
and you have to make sure you read
everything accurately yes
on that day to miss williams did you say
justin is a threat
a big one
we bought cameras last night at home
depot to plant
in the barn
and in our apartment so we can always
see what justin is doing
and saying
yes i said i wrote that i lied to my
friend
so she wouldn't be worried though the
situation with justin that she knew
about
i didn't want her to worry i just told
her don't worry about it
got cameras handles
and that was it
now
at some point
you know
that but michael barrison knows
that you're recording him correct
yeah about
five months later romans later
died in april threats
so
the the shooting day he came to shoot us
and kill us was that was august 7 of
august 7th
so yes so several months later
is when we purchased the cameras that
that's what you're asking
is that what you guys have no idea
hold on just
listen to the question and and try to
answer only the question as i said
earlier if you don't understand yes just
say i don't understand can you rephrase
okay yes
i'll rephrase it
right i think you should go ahead you
at some point you buy cameras correct
yes at some point you start tape
recording
private conversations correct
by cameras
yes
team recording private country yes i
guess that would be accurate statement
yes okay and
at some point prior to the shooting
after you started
tape recording private conversations
you became aware that michael barrisson
believed or knew
that you were doing that to him
um guessings
i told the police i'm guessing i don't
know i don't know what he was aware of
i have no way of knowing that i'm sorry
august 5th two days before the shooting
did you tell your father in a text
message
and i confirmed for sure
that they know we have a bug in the barn
did you make that statement to your
father probably yes it's been a text
message i've i made the statement
you're asking did i make it i'm asking
you rather than someone else
i'll show you this
100 c8
specific item 42.
please look at this specific text
okay i'm going to go there
for that for some context
yes that was written by me
does that refresh your recollection as
to whether or not
you became aware
that michael barrisson
knew
or at least thought that you were
recording his private conversations no
well i think it indicates
what it indicates which is that
i told the police officer
this
so i figured probably it might have
gotten back to him
they wanted to continue having those
conversations in front of my locker
that they now know
like i said we were trying to do things
as legally as possible because i can't
know what michael was thinking oh it was
actually told to him well what did you
mean my father here in text message so
what did you mean when you used the word
and i confirmed for sure
that they know we have a bug in the barn
what did you mean by the term
confirmed for sure i meant that i told a
police officer meaning that i figured
that if it were some problem
they would know about it even if it
weren't a problem they might tell i
didn't know like least protocol
so it was just an assumption i was
writing to my father
again
in the context of that whole
conversation
i would say that it would make sense for
me to say that which we didn't get into
that
now let's go back to july 25th
okay
did you post a note another lengthy
post regarding mary haskins and michael
barrison
it's 11 days after the first one that i
read about the king and the queen
[Music]
how many days before the shooting was
this
this one is
july 25th
okay i'll just confirm how many days
later i've been continuing i'm sorry
and and by the way did the prosecutor
ever ask you for the
receipt from your amazon
account
to determine when you got those three
quarters
i wouldn't know like i said i was in a
coma for four days
in the icu for three weeks unable to
speak
because i had a ventilator shut down my
throat
and after that i was on so many pain
medications
i really couldn't communicate with
anyone
so i have no idea what was said or done
like my life was almost ended
do you recall saying words to the effect
that uh it turns out once a home wrecker
always a home record
were you referring to mary haskins
absolutely
did you then say words to the effect
that then
said homewrecker realized if her man did
it to his wife
wives
what's to stop him from straying again
did you say that yep and there's i think
six more chapters i know them all right
and then
did you say immediately after that
here's where paranoia and jealously set
in
yes
i'm familiar with the post yes and it's
your
belief that mary haskins was jealous of
you
um i think she was jealous of a lot of
people
and it was just an insecurity that she
had that was that was my belief yes
did you say a little bit later on in
that post
when talking about barista and mary
haskins
did you say
it's war
probably mr belinkus when you
characterize something
don't you characterize it
that's what it says it's wrong
no no before that
you're saying who she's talking about
okay you're not testifying she is ask
her that question understood
the previous statement that i read you
were referring to barrister and mary
haskins correct can you read the
previous statement again so i'm sure
what's to stop him from straying again
here's where
paranoia and jealousy set in
yes
that's
a statement that i wrote you wrote that
and it's about barista and haskins
correct correct and then soon after that
you basically make a statement and
correct me if i'm wrong where you say
it's war
correct
yeah probably i'd say so
and correct me if i'm wrong but
going to war was against barrisone and
mary haskins correct i mean i don't know
you didn't read i only got
the one sentence i didn't get the whole
context
so i don't exactly know
i'm sure we're talking about going to
war against anyone else
during this period no but like i'm
saying
all i'm bringing up is that i feel that
maybe
some context left out but it's fine we
can just go with yes i wrote that
i meant that that's fine we can move on
not go back to that all right
just ma'am just answer the question
all right
now
and this is the post that a lot of
people are looking at correct well how
does she know that
because it's facebook
just focus on the issues and the issue
how many times mr blancas is not
everyone
i understand so what other people know
is not really relevant
did you say in that state that you will
publicly announce
using your special talents for
collecting
indisputable evidence
or words to that
yes
did you tell
whoever saw this facebook post later on
to fasten their seat
belts yes
a story like this
even told that a distance may cause
whiplash
it's that bad
yes it definitely said that
including
extra stories that could only be heard
in recordings or videos
to be fully believed
yes
so on this day
which is july 25th
you're telling whoever's reading this
that you have evidence
videos
and
recordings correct
i thought the sentence was
um
could you read the sentence again
actually extra stories could only be
heard in a recording or video
to be fully believed we talked about
recordings and videos correct talked
about
that they could only be believed if they
were in a recording or a video which is
what led us to later get those two very
things
to make sure they believed
did you say towards the end
even a one-time olympian
can be cut down to size
yes
and then oh yes a war
i fear
may be inevitable
yes and then at the very end
i'll need all the calm of the dead sea
to stop me from totally going totally
ballistic
probably yes
now
michael barrasson was
living in his home
at the facility correct when you came
back
uh in the summer of
2019. correct
i'm sorry i'm unclear okay
the facility the
the farm
well he was living in one place the year
before and then another place the year
after so
i'm talking about
the summer of
2019 when you
you were living with your your boyfriend
in the upstairs apartment
correct okay michael barrisson was
living on the main floor there yes with
mary haskins and their small child
correct yes
yes
okay
um that that was his house correct
um i i assumed that was at the time yes
you you were living in an apartment
and were not paying him any rent correct
for the apartment
we were paying we were was a barter
agreement right right
and when you say the barter agreement
you were paying
just to
board two horses at 2500
apiece
at that point correct
plus
i think i believe forty thousand dollars
i just given him for
a horse he was unable to sell
plus um
the work that my boyfriend had done
along the barn in the house which
michael said was
gonna be compensated um and part of that
compensation
was that
we have the housing whenever although
that was established the year before
and that
the main part of it would be
when my other horse that i purchased
would come overseas
so michael could train her
um
he chose
the facility she would be quarantined at
so yes
we were paying a lot of money more than
just the five thousand dollars that you
said two weeks living in that apartment
there was the work done like i mentioned
there was the money given to him for the
horse that he couldn't sell
and
so yes
we're living in a house and paying money
yes
again let's let's break this down if we
could sure
when you first
come
to his facility you only have two horses
correct when i first come yes
and the agreement was
that you would pay five thousand dollars
for those two horses
and he agreed to give you living
accommodations correct
training of those two horses
living accommodations
and rewarding yeah so yeah yes correct
okay so
that's the deal that did you cut that
deal or did your father cut that deal
um it was a joint
i guess conversation discussion
well who pays for the
board
what do you mean who pays the 5 000 you
or your father it comes out of my money
and my father writes the check
and where does he get the money from
the bank
okay
so
your father's
taking the money out of your account or
his account
my account
does it does it matter mr belinkas
what's the relevance to this i'll move
on
so the original deal was that you would
board and train your horses and
give you living accommodations correct
that original agreement did not include
your boyfriend living on the property
did it
um
i told michael i was bringing my
boyfriend and then i had two dogs i
wanted to make sure he knew that in case
it was a pet issue
or whatever
he said on the phone or hour-long
conversation
no problem
and then he sent a text to my father
which read something like she's gonna
love the apartment they're gonna love it
um
it's so wonderful it even has antiques
my father then sent me that message i
read it i said all right sounds like a
plan
i guess
i can't really say no to this offer it's
too good to be true or refused and we
took the offer
gratefully
did you ever tell the prosecutors that
in the beginning you didn't know your
boyfriend were coming
i don't know i don't think so but i
could not be sure
so when you came up from florida
after the winter of
2018
how many horses
were you boarding when you first came up
when i first came to meet michael union
yes in new jersey
how many actual forces were in his
stable two the same two from florida
okay
so
and the same arrangement
basically held true correct
correct until things changed yes
horses for five thousand dollars
and the living accommodation correct
and then there came a time when
you brought in two more horses correct
there came a time when
i
purchased a horse from michael
making that
the third worth or sorry
making that third horse correct so that
was the horse that michael wanted off
his hands
i peed for the horse we agreed that i
paid for the horse
the horse gets to state where he's lived
his whole life
and
no change is made
training will be included because
horse has shivers he's got a lot of
health issues
yadda yadda
bottom line i say michael
here i'm going to give you this money
first horse you've got these issues but
he shouldn't be moved from his home
so i buy the horse from michael he then
says okay
you know you just buy the horse he'll
keep the stall
you'll keep taking lessons on him like
usual nothing changes okay now what's
the name of that door jt
now
compressively if i'm wrong you're making
it sound as if
it took some lame horse off force off
his hands
that's that's your position my position
is that the horse had issues health
issues serious ones including cushions
um
shivers
i can name a bunch of other things
really bad cases shivers
and
yes i bought the horse
because i've written him all the time
others didn't get along with him i did
i fell in love with the damn horse
excuse my language
and
i bought them
and michael agreed that it was probably
best because
probably
he wouldn't get
anywhere near the money he would have
gotten had the force
not had these issues
so
i bought him
paid a lot of money for him
kept him
and then michael invited me to bring
that another horse
and then hit another horse but i guess
okay let's let's talk about jt okay sure
but before we do that can i see council
at the bench please
go to another area please
all right so
2019 you have two horses you buy jt
which makes a third horse correct
you're still only paying five thousand
dollars correct
five thousand plus the 30 or 40 that i
just paid michael for the horse that
i've gotten then yes okay that that has
nothing to do with the monthly fee that
you're paying that's
it's not a monthly fee that was a
one-time payment
done finished or sold
okay and
and then
you get another horse correct
no i already had well now i already own
those horses
did you bring another horse to barista
yes they bought a fourth horse when was
that when was that may
some if there's a post on facebook
actually so you should have it
um
where she actually arrived that day
and
whatever the day it was maybe june 7th i
want to say
um
no
i don't remember oh the word i don't
know okay and sometime in june correct i
believe in june it might have been
earlier and can i assume that you
started paying another 25. mr balance i
just ruled on this
this is not i find this not relevant
for the reasons i just stated at sidebar
since this is totally different
all right mr balinkas move on
my ruling stance i don't find it
relevant
this is cataract
at some point in time
you start
bad-mouthing michael barrasso
to people in the industry and on social
media correct
correct
you
tell people that he abuses and neglect
forces correct
i don't know if i said all that but it
could be correct it did happen so i
might have said it
you even called him a a criminal
i don't believe i called him criminal
it's possible though i'm not gonna say
it never happened well did you claim
that that flood
that occurred at the farmhouse when he
was in florida with mary haskins
was an insurance game
and i probably claimed that on facebook
somewhere yes you probably you don't
have a specific recollection of telling
people that he committed insurance fraud
no i only have the specific reflection
of what he himself said about it i don't
remember whether or not i decided to go
blabbing on facebook about it that day
or not
maybe i did i sometimes do not my best
choice
but it could have happened
now and you realize that insurance fraud
is a crime correct
oh yes i realized that and so when i
ask you the question did you
accuse him of a crime
you realize by
calling him someone who's committed
insurance fraud that that is accusing
him of a crime correct
i mean
yeah i did go to the police about it and
report him
you know because then if i didn't have
exact
proof
i don't want to be accused of making
some of the erroneous report
so
i was expressing my feelings on it based
on what we had heard him say to us
himself and we very much believed that
at one point he did not want the
information that we had about that
getting out right well then you told
everybody on social media whatever
you thought you had correct
probably you contacted safe sport the
town
maybe other agencies
did you ever contact the insurance
company and give them this evidence that
you had
no i did speak to the insurance adjuster
though
and he made it very clear that he had
some
i don't know
i don't know how to articulate it he had
some arrangement with michael and you
could not discuss it and he left but we
i just wanted to ask him a couple of
questions
and he wasn't having it so i left it
alone
at that point
you just said that you were aware of the
fact that
michael barristone didn't even negotiate
the
fraud claim there was a private adjuster
that did that
correct you talked to him there was
somebody that said they were probably
i'm going to object at this point to the
relevance that i think this is getting
far afield
i'm just
questioning her answers to the questions
as to what she do and what she said and
again
you brought out that she accused him of
insurance fraud
[Music]
no that's what's relevant so move on
sustained now three days before the
shooting
were you posting on facebook
that everything from my life
livelihood and even writing career
have all been threatened
should i refuse to adhere to the things
i've been put through constantly
i did yes
like that
and who is threatening your
life
and livelihood as you read
um michael barason and his girlfriend
mary haskins and how were they doing
that
several ways
they were calling
barnes and
trainers
from
michael's higher up powerful like
olympian friends
to your average
you know next door barn telling them
that we're menaces we're torturing them
we're terrors
and
then at the same time
you know making it like we need to leave
or they didn't want us there so
i guess
in
the best way to describe it it was it
was like a turning they're trying
we felt they're trying to like trap us
there saying
oh you know you have to leave my
girlfriend doesn't like you but oh yeah
you also can't go anywhere else because
you've been calling every single place
telling them don't take their horses
that was happening
um then the girlfriend
was calling
not just calling
um michael and the girlfriend
weren't just going they were actually
going so far as the cyber stalk
all of my social media pages
back to up to like five years to see if
i ever had a
conflict with anyone
and then
get that person involved
in this dispute
whether i had not spoken to that person
five years
two years ten years it didn't matter
they were doing things that were not
okay
by any of the governing bodies of the
sport
by any of the governing bodies of all
the sports and quite frankly by the law
since they were cyber stalking my page
when you say cyber smoking your face
first of all you indicated that they
were content contacting people that knew
you correct
i don't know who among them yes
and also other people
michael
wrote um in a text message
to
how did you see the text message twitter
it was posted publicly on twitter
that michael posted
literally these words i'm a very big guy
in the olympics i have a lot of power
here or whatever
um
i i'm good friends with the head counts
with the ceo
murray kessler
um
and the chief of staff or the chief
counsel
sonia keating i have a lot of power
there
like basically once you've gone to the
olympics you have all this power so
um you know
i'm gonna be able to do whatever i want
encouraging this he said i'm gonna be
able to do whatever i want in that
twitter something like that i'm
paraphrasing most of these things
you know like you sort of have a little
bit but
um
yes
in
the infants that you're discussing
yes on twitter it's public
posted publicly
the text message that michael barcelona
wrote to this person
saying
mary haskins said she found you online
she's never met you i'm this big guy in
olympic sports i have a lot of friends
i'm good best friends or good friends
with the head counsel
murray kessler who's the ceo
um
oh the lead counsel sonia keating good
friend as well
basically asserting his power
he's this big olympian
who can bully us peons
into submission in whatever way he wants
on an anger tan or a temper tantrum and
get others involved in doing it which a
safe sport is an abuse of power
which to the law i'm sure is cyber
stalking i don't know
and to uscf our oversight body but also
be weaponization of the oversight body
and
a violation of their code right as you
all
and you think that by him
contacting these people
and and talking to them about you and
what is going on specifically the
postings that you're making
the bad-mouthing that you're doing of
him and that all his stuff that there's
something inappropriate with him
checking you out
or conducting an investigation as to who
you really are
i'm sorry i missed i missed the question
in that that's the reason that you just
stated in your last answer
is the reason why you claimed in this
post that your life and livelihood
have all been threatened yes when an
olympian blatantly says to someone in a
text message i am going to ruin this
person's life who said that michael said
it he said there is a text out there or
any post can you let her finish mr blink
please i withdraw the question
is there any actually would you believe
there is a text out there
that he wrote okay did you give that
text to the prosecutor
for him to use in this court courtroom
no i do not where is that text that you
just said michael barrisson said he was
going to ruin your life well we heard
him saying it we heard he texted people
this
saying he's going to ruin our lives and
quote
find a way to make our lives hell
we got wind of the fact that he was in
fact doing that when we spoke to
another person who i'm not going to
bring into at the moment
i'm sure we'll come in later
um
but like i said for all the world to see
he put on display by texting this woman
that he is this big guy in olympics
and
that she in fact a person
who's not even a horse person
should immediately
call
these
gov sorry oversight bodies and make
complaints against us
and this is a person i had a personal
dispute with
that ended years prior
and
was telling her
make this complaint
and don't worry it's okay i'm a big guy
in olympic sports no one's gonna that's
what that's how the text reads
that
what was question
don't even think about going there mr
blinkist move on we're going down a
rabbit hole here
move on i need a yes or no answer if you
can answer that way
is there a text message to support what
you just said in your last answer where
michael barrisson said he was going to
destroy your life
um yes or no if i recall correctly there
is
okay i would not i would not swear my
life on it those exact words were used
but i would testify that
some words bad effects were used in the
text did you tell that to prosecutor
shellhorn
i don't know i honestly don't know i
mean we have voices in many
conversations
you're aware of the fact that
we have all of his texas your texas
mm-hmm
i don't know that that's accurate yeah
mr bolenkos
ignore that members of the jury ask
another question please
would it surprise you to know that
michael barrasson doesn't have a twitter
account
no it wouldn't surprise me he has a
facebook account though well you just
said you saw it on twitter correct yes i
saw it posted by another person on
twitter another person
yes a text
made by michael barissone
to
this person
and this person posted
a screen a photo
of that message
on twitter in fact there were several of
them
some of them are still there some have
been deleted in screenshot some are
still there right now
all right let's
let me ask you this did you ever post
something
regarding barristone and mary haskins
and then delete it
not that i recall unless uh facebook
took it down or
um
a site that thought like a post was
inappropriate if that edit or delete it
i do not recall deleting any posts
that's
more of mary haskins thing you just
talked about having
or listening to recorded conversations
between michael barrasson and his staff
concerning you
did there come a
time when you would use those words
to taunt him
his own words taunt him yes no no we're
not called that
would
what do you call when you pay
post
private conversations that someone has
on social media
do you think that that would have an
impact on your answer yes how many
questions just one at a time let her
answer and then you ask a follower i
would think that since
in those very recordings that you're
speaking of he literally says listen i'm
not asking you what he said well i'm
going to ask you mr bolenko she's not
answering the question judge
i i don't know because you cut her off
i don't know if she's answering it or
not i'll withdraw the question
i think you should withdraw and move on
to another area
this cataract
did you
post
private conversations that you recorded
of michael barrisson
on social media
yes i did
did you text him
some of the private conversations that
you had recorded
i
don't think so
maybe i can't imagine i would text him
i reported you saying this no but
i don't know i don't know the answer i'm
sorry
let's turn to august 6 the day before
the shooting okay
um i do i have that no i'm going to ask
you some questions with regards to a
facebook post that was posted for
everyone to see
um
this is the one where you start off
where you say some advice to all couples
never give an ultimatum
yeah remember that this is the post you
just read a few seconds ago
august 6th well why don't you why don't
you show it to us so we can get it clear
i'm showing your facebook posts page
3135
yes
[Music]
i think that's page
3135 of s402
just so the record
is clear about what the team shows
[Music]
did you
read this is this your facebook post
that goes on to the second page yes this
is the one where you read about the home
record girlfriend and vk no this is this
is this is a different one august 6th
yes the sixth chapter post that we
talked about nope
[Music]
we haven't gone over this one this is
another one
august 6 2019.
now you start off this social media post
by saying
never give an ultimatum
[Music]
did you hear anyone in your secret
recording
give michael an ultimatum
[Music]
i have no idea probably actually yes i
did
but and i don't know how direct they
were
i don't know how to answer that question
yes they're ultimatums given
and you've heard that in private
conversations
who were the ultimatums given by
mary haskins in some cases
um
[Music]
michael i believe in smother mary
defranco
and quite a few
and these were all captured
from your
locker in this stable area that's
correct they would all gather on the
bench
and discuss things
why they were doing it in front of my
locker i couldn't say
but
i mean there are horses walking by
so
horses typically don't go in living
areas
have you listened to all these types
there's not horses going by now
mr bulenkos
come on
enough for the comments please
just ask a question get an answer ask
another question
[Music]
now with regards to this post which is
the day before the shooting
you're talking about and correct me if
i'm wrong
people that give ultimatures
tend to be miserable and insecure people
correct
and again you say correctly if i'm wrong
numerous world-class show animals and
even
managed to get the human
husband
on an alternate list for a coveted spot
in the olympics
and produce winning competitors prior
and
you put in
parentheses
again just a random example
thank you
when you posted things like that
did you
intentionally
make a statement and try to cover your
tracks with a another statement like
that's only examples i'm not talking
about you
or
using metaphors did you try to
disguise who you were talking about
probably
so that it wouldn't be
i'll just leave it yes probably that
would make sense
will you agree with me that it's clear
in this
post that you're talking about barista
it's clear to me yes
or to anybody that knows barry solar
haskins correct and that knows i'm
training with them and that's where i'm
located and that
had they
made these phone calls
bad-mouthing us for what we believe is
no reason they might come to my page and
say
okay there's another side of the story
and i wouldn't have to
say a name or out anybody so that anyone
else would know
but
those people that we discussed
were getting phone calls
that
were not involved in anything going on
would maybe come to my page and say okay
there's more to this than what we're
hearing from
their side at the moment and is it true
that when you're making these posts you
always try to qualify things to a
certain extent extent to protect
yourself correct
yeah probably yeah like for instance
where you said here
upon this hypothetical
husband in quotes
return
he had in tow with him a much younger
woman
who hosted said clinton not pretty on
the outside or nice on the inside just
fightful
adulterous
and insecure
did you say that about mary haskins yes
so
[Music]
did you say that
after the divorce
that mary haskins
she began discussing plans to remodel
the home
her boyfriend once shared with his wife
mr blinkist
let me see that cyborg please
all right move on mr blancas
or is this a good time to break mr
balance it's 4 25 i think it is hi it's
my wife's
well we don't we don't need to get into
that just just tell me yes it's time to
break
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll
break for today please don't discuss the
case
all right we'll see you tomorrow morning
same time
[Music]
you can step down man you just wait
outside
just don't walk down that edge just stay
down this end until the prosecutor comes
out all right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
don't have ever comment to the jury
about anything in your personal life
all right it's inappropriate
i know but it's not it's not necessary
it's just not it's completely
unnecessary and it's
yeah yes no it's why do they have to
know that
what do they have to know that
it is a big deal
it is a big deal you shouldn't have any
communications with the jury
you